Hello everybody!
Woah!
Sorry, let me pause this video.
I downloaded the trailer.
Hello everybody!
Hello, hello!
Oh my god.
I feel so relaxed right now.
It's been a while.
I hope you guys are okay with the low supply of vitamin doki.
It was sort of like an unplanned rest week because I did say I was like, I'm gonna take like three days off.
And then it ended up like I just disappeared.
And then Twitch was like, oh doki's having a rest week?
Time to invite her to Twitch Rivals.
And then I got invited to the Fortnite Twitch Rivals.
And then that stuff shit happened.
Oh my god, Kevlar said yes to it.
It was so funny.
I'm fucking sweaty.
Like why am I there?
To be fair, at least like I wasn't last.
Like that's all that matters.
I wasn't last.
But yes, I feel like, I feel like super relaxed right now.
I don't remember how to stream at the moment.
I'm at this, you know like when you haven't done something in a while.
So then you're just like, I don't like...
Doki, you were there yesterday at EVA.
What do you... Okay, but that's different.
I have like four other people to talk for me.
Um, and then so I had four other people to talk for me.
So it wasn't like actually streaming.
It was just hanging out with the boys.
Like hanging out with the homies.
For those who don't know, because for those who don't follow me on Twitter, I really apologize that the YouTube people who don't follow me on Twitter and being like, what do you mean?
You, you were doing a watch party of EVA.
Um, so on Twitter, that's why you got to create a Twitter account just to follow me.
Um, but I showed up at the, I guess it's sort of official watch party.
Um, one of the official watch parties for EVA, which was a team Brawl Pro.
Uh, so a lot of people thought I was going to show up because they only showed like all the other members in team Brawl Pro.
So Brawl Pro, God Brawl Pro, your name is so hard to pronounce sometimes when I'm talking like, like in a moderately fast speed.
But, um, I'm afraid of Twitter.
That's why you only follow me because all I do is just retweet art, retweet merch, retweet some fans to interaction and also tweet my streams like and sponsors.
That's why you only follow me because there's nothing else but just doki stuff.
Uh, anyway, um, so, um, it was like sort of like a surprise guest appearance because I didn't think I was going to be there as well.
Um, but then like I, I messaged like, uh, the day before.
Because I saw, you know, everybody was like taking pictures, hanging out and everything.
Um, why did I not announce that I wasn't going to EVO?
Because I didn't want to like, you know, I wanted to like sort of separate.
I didn't want people to sort of like know where I was type deal.
So that's why like I didn't say it because I know a lot of people are like, are you going to be at EVO?
Are you going to be at EVO?
If I say yes, people will try to find me.
If I say no, um, then like that gives a precedence of like whether or not I'm going to show up somewhere.
Like, you know, I'm willing to say where I'm going to show up because I don't want, I don't really like I'm, I don't really want to show up.
I really want like, uh, people to like approach me out of nowhere.
Because I'm an introvert.
So I feel pretty awkward about that type of situation.
So that's why I didn't say whether or not I was going to be there or not.
So like, like, you know, if I'm going to be somewhere, I wouldn't announce it.
I wouldn't say it.
That's why I never, I never, I never said like, Um, that's why I never, I never, I never said like, I never like, I don't want to like set precedence of whether or not like I'll be like, no, I won't be there.
And so then people assume that I'll tell people where I'm going to be next time.
Um, so like, that's why I was like, oh, people would be like, are you going to be there?
And I'm like, I can't say yes or no.
That's literally what I meant.
I can't confirm or deny.
But I didn't want to like, you know, be like, I wasn't going to be there.
Um, but it was because I had a really, I needed a break.
And, um, I needed to like, there was a lot of stuff going on as well.
So sadly I wasn't there.
Uh, I wasn't there physically at EVO.
So, but I did like, uh, I did like, that doesn't mean like, uh, Seijan was really nice about it and said like, if I ever want to go anywhere, like they can use that money to fund the thing for me next time.
Um, because I said, unfortunately I can't make it to this year's EVO and stuff like that.
Um, so, uh, Seijan was incredibly nice about it.
And he was like, oh, don't worry.
If you ever want to try to go to any EVOs in the future, because they announced like three fucking EVOs.
Yesterday, Seijan was like, we will help fund you for that.
And, um, uh, like the same prize, the same prize as the like winning Seijan slam type deal.
So I really appreciate it.
He's such a nice guy, um, in general.
Um, but anyway, yes, I was at the, I guess it wasn't official.
It was an official watch party, but it was hosted on team of Brawl Pro, like Mr. Brawl Pro's channel.
Um, so it was me, Koni, Sly.
Matt and, uh, Brawl Pro.
We were all there just hanging out.
Um, just watching.
I was just going to be there for Tekken.
Um, but, uh, but then like, you know, it was like Street Fighter was like the finals, like the last match.
I had no idea what was going on.
Um, but Street Fighter was like the last turn, like the last tournament before EVO ends.
And I was like, you know what?
I'll stay as well.
Uh, so.
It was great.
It was a great time watching.
Um, um, I remember like, I haven't watched EVO in a long ass time.
Like I've seen like best of moments where, you know, the celebrations and stuff like that.
Like people celebrating.
I've seen stuff, clips of that.
Like, um, of like the endings of EVO events, like EVO tournaments and stuff.
I never like, really, I haven't watched an actual like, tournaments in EVO in a long ass time.
Um, so it was great experiencing that again.
Um, and, uh, and I had a great time.
I had a great time with the boys and we took a picture and everything.
Matt was really nice.
Cause I asked Matt if he could like help me take a picture with everybody.
And then like, I called in on a lazy Matt man's phone and then like, uh, put the camera on and everything.
That's how we got the photo together.
And then we all got together and had the photo.
I was really happy about that.
Cause, um, originally, originally it was just to take a photo.
Um, with.
I just wanted to take a photo with the team because I saw everybody was having such a fun time together.
Um, on Twitter.
So I messaged, uh, I messaged Matt and BrawlPro.
I messaged BrawlPro if I could take a photo with the team, um, before everything ends.
And then he was like, yeah, yeah, of course.
Uh, of course we like, of course we want to.
And then, so, um, that turned into like, wait, can I actually show up at the watch party?
And then they literally got me into the watch party the day after.
Like, um, I think like I asked the day before and then they got everything ready to set up like this, the morning of the watch party.
So in the morning, um, they're like, they messaged me and they added me into this big group chat with the EVO team at like the EVO technical team.
Um, like the people were running like EVO and stuff.
So they, they set the production team of EVO in a group chat with me.
And, um, and then like in the morning of, I had to do like a tech rehearsal.
Uh, because they haven't really added a YouTuber, you know, on the broadcast before.
I think, I think, am I, I don't know, I'm not sure.
I might be like, spitting words under my ass right now.
But, but like the production team didn't really, um, never really done it before.
So we were doing like a technical test and everything.
Um, and, uh, at like 11 in the morning.
And then after that, like I came in.
Um, at like, you know, at like 3pm and stuff to get ready for the watch party.
But it was a great time.
I had a, uh, had a great time.
And, um, it was a great experience.
Uh, I really love Team Brawl Pro.
Uh, honestly, I think it's like one of the best experiences I've had as a YouTuber in a tournament setting.
And, um, it was great meeting them.
And I'm really happy that I was able to do a watch party with them.
Anyway, on other news, it was so, I need to tell you guys a story.
Uh, but during my rest week, I had to do like another technical test for, uh, um, ACGHK for one of the conventions I'm doing.
And in one of the conventions, we're doing, we're, uh, I'll be playing Apex with some fans, um, during ACGHK.
And it was so funny because I had to do a technical test.
And, um, they wanted me to play a game of Apex.
Uh, to check the sound and everything.
And so, so, you know, it was me, the production team for the convention and the call, and my events manager.
So, you know, we were, they were all listening in to the gameplay.
And while I was playing in the middle of this game, the lifeline player in my team was like, Yo, Doki, you wanna, you wanna...
He was like, yo, Doki, you wanna, like, squad up?
And then I'm just like, what the fuck?
And I was like, well, like...
And then everybody was, you know, we were on top.
Like, we were all, like, trying to do the technical test.
And then, so, like, everybody heard that.
And then I was just like, this is so awkward.
And so then in the chat, I was just like, um...
Like, I typed out, um...
And then he was like, the guy in the game was like, bro, bro, trust me, I'm a fucking goaded lifeline.
And then everybody just laughed.
And then, and then, like, the production team and my event manager just laughed.
And then they were laughing their ass off.
And I'm like, bro...
And then I was like, I can't tell.
I was like, bro, I'm doing a fucking technical test right now.
And he was like, he doesn't know.
Like, the staff was, like, just laughing at him.
And I'm like, oh, he doesn't know.
It was so funny.
I'm like, bro, bro, not the time right now, man.
He lacks the critical information.
Um...
But anyway, during my rest week, um...
It was just some random...
I just bumped into some fucking random lifeline player.
Anyway, so...
Juno, the newest support, just came out.
Well, the testing of Juno just came out.
But...
Me, not being able to read, didn't realize that Juno was only available on Friday, Saturday, and Sunday.
I thought Juno was gonna be there forever.
I didn't realize it was just, like, a technical preview of her.
So I was, like, super excited.
Because I was like, oh, I'm gonna take a rest this...
Like, you know, I'm gonna take a rest.
And then I'll check her out after, like, rest week is over.
Little do I know, today is the day that she actually was officially not available to play.
So I never got a chance to check her out.
So...
I never read the details.
I was like, JUNO!
And then I was like, oh my god, like that movie!
But also...
Um, anyway...
Juno is pretty interesting.
Because she's basically every support combined together.
So a lot of people are saying that she might make Lucio obsolete.
Because she has a support.
And she has a speed boost.
Um...
And her ult is a speed, like, ult.
So she has, like...
You know, Lucio's whole thing is speed boost.
So that's, like, unfortunate for him.
Um...
But everybody was saying that she's really, really fun to play.
I'm really sad I couldn't check her out before she gets nerfed.
Because, you know, in the previews...
Um...
I'm pretty sure she's gonna get, like, adjusted and nerfed.
Before...
Because she's coming out next season.
She's coming out in August.
So I'm just really sad.
Because I really want to try her out.
During, like, the actual...
Um...
The actual, like, gameplay time.
When, like, she's, like, fresh.
And, um...
Hasn't been touched yet by devs or anything.
Because the devs are already saying that, like...
Oh, we're gonna adjust her after the technical preview.
So I'm a little bit sad.
I'm actually...
I'm really sad!
Because she must have...
She was gonna be the strongest she ever was.
Like, during the technical test.
Uh...
So...
Yeah...
But other than that...
Uh...
She has, like...
DP...
She's, like...
She has Ana, Lucio, Mercy, and...
There was something else.
It was, like...
People were saying that she has, like, Ana, Mercy, Lucio combined together.
Um...
So I thought that was incredibly interesting.
Because, like...
You know...
And that...
She requires aim.
Because you have to shoot people to heal.
Which is always a great thing.
Because, uh...
I like characters that has, like...
Skill.
I'm so sorry for, like...
If I insult anybody who plays, like...
The non-aiming characters.
But I like playing support characters that require actual skill.
Uh...
Because I find them just more fun.
Bro!
Lucio is so hard to aim!
It's literally a projectile!
You cannot say that!
Lucio was, like...
Okay.
You clearly played with bot Lucios who don't move.
Who don't even wall-ride.
Lucio rollouts!
Lucio projectiles!
Lucio is all about living to...
You gotta live to keep your team up!
You have good movement!
Anyway...
Um...
As I was saying...
As...
As I was...
As I was saying...
Um...
I would...
I feel like Juno seems like an incredibly fun character to play.
I asked one of my friends, like...
Cuz, like, they tried out Juno during the weekend.
Cuz, I was like...
Oh, I realized Juno's not available anymore.
What is Juno like?
And then they were telling me, like...
Oh yeah, like...
Um...
She's really fun to play.
And that she has a lot of abilities.
Uh...
She has a lot of abilities and, like...
To keep track of.
So she's gonna have a very high ceiling.
Um...
Skill ceiling.
Which is great!
I like that.
I like that some heroes have, like...
High skill ceilings.
I still...
Okay, like...
There's, like, a couple of heroes that I still have never learned.
Because I realized, like...
When they came out...
I realized that they were never gonna be meta in support.
It's the worst thing!
Okay...
Uh...
The biggest issue with a lot of newest support characters that they add in...
Other than, like, Kiriko...
Is that...
They never become meta.
Um...
Like, they never become, like, support meta.
Other than Kiriko.
So, like...
Life Weaver...
He was, like, dog shit.
Uh...
Baptiste...
Like, there were, like, other characters you could play.
Ilari...
Same there.
Unless you're a DPS player that just wants the DPS.
But then...
To have a good Ilari...
In order to make Ilari a good...
Uh...
Pick...
You have to have a really good...
Um...
Support partner.
To help keep everybody up.
Because Ilari is, like, half DPS...
Like, majority DPS and then support.
Um...
And then also, like, good...
Like, placement on the...
The pylons.
Um...
Bapt has been...
No, he's not...
He's not meta.
You can pick him!
But he's not, like...
He's not, like, meta meta.
Like, you can pick him and it's not considered throwing.
Ilari is...
He's not meta meta.
Like, you can pick him but it's...
You're not really throwing when you're picking him.
But there's, like, better supports to play.
I feel like...
Because, like, I feel like...
Uh...
You know...
Other than...
Instead of playing Bap, you could play Kiriko instead.
Uh...
Due to, like, Kiriko...
Like, if I had to choose between Baptiste and Kiriko, I would pick Kiriko.
Because it's, like, similar kit.
Um...
And then I usually play Ana because Ana has been, like, fucking...
Like...
I mean, like...
Kiriko is better because she cleanses.
I honestly think Kiriko is, like, better because she cleanses than Bap's kit.
So that's why, like, if I had to choose between the two, I'll just play Kiriko.
Um...
But Ana has always been, like, hard meta for, like, a while now.
And then I play Zenyatta.
Yeah, Ana is always, like, top three.
Um...
Bap is also mostly, like, if your teammates are, like, incredibly W-killed.
Yeah.
Like, if they're lucky and they just wanna die, you pick Bap just for the heals.
Like...
Is there any time...
Like, if you have a Rein player, a Rein main, and I didn't avoid the Rein main, um...
Usually, people will go Bap because, like, you know, just to keep the fucking Rein alive.
So that's why...
That's why people will go Baptiste.
That's, like, literally the only time I see people pick Bap because they're, like, alright, this Reinhardt...
This Reinhardt wants to fucking die.
So I gotta pick Baptiste so, like, he doesn't do that.
Like...
Um...
Daisy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I lost a lot of faith in the hero design team since Overwatch 2 launched.
To be honest, most of them have been crazy OP or crazy underpowered.
And a lot have not been that fun.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Apparently, Juno is very different from, like, a lot of the heroes that they released.
Um...
I like how, like, the day after this stream, I'm playing Marble Rivals so we can have, like, fresh comparison between the two.
Because, like, Marble Rivals is technically gonna be, like, Overwatch's competitor.
Even though it is third person.
Um...
So, like, we get to, like, you know, compare it directly in between the two.
Uh...
Um...
Anyway.
Uh...
I heard Juno was incredibly fun to play.
And also, like, you know, it revitalized a certain community for Overwatch.
So, you know, I guess it's, like, a win-win situation for everybody.
You know?
If you know, you know.
Alright.
Let's watch the trailer.
I watched a little bit of the trailer.
Um...
I heard she's, like- she works with Mei.
Like, in the lore...
Uh...
In the lore atmosphere, she works with- she used to work with Mei.
Um...
So, I thought that was really interesting.
But no one really pays attention to the Overwatch.
They fired the person who did the Overwatch lore.
So, like, I don't know what's going on anymore.
So...
AHAHAHA!
What?
Did they fire the head guy who did the Overwatch lore?
Like, um, so... I don't know what's going on anymore.
So I haven't been paying much attention to the lore.
Like, in the beginning... in the beginning, the lore was really interesting.
But I felt like the more it went on, the more confusing it got.
So I don't know.
It got like super convoluted.
And like lots of retcons were happening.
So like I stopped paying attention to it.
No one really pays attention to the lore anyway these days.
Woo!
Alright, so that's the spaceship where she comes from.
Yay!
Oh, it's like a tracer gun!
I just noticed it.
I don't like the font.
I really... I don't know.
It feels like...
Middle School PowerPoint Project.
I don't know.
That's what the font reminds me of.
Like, it looks like fucking PowerPoint.
Middle School PowerPoint.
Like, I was always like, my wife is so cute.
Do you know what she reminds... Oh!
That's what...
She reminds me of the fucking idol girl in Marvel Rivals where she dances to heel.
I'd be like, come on guys!
Dance to heel!
Let's go!
That's what she reminds... Cause it's the gliding!
I wonder if it was inspired by that.
Yeah, Dazzler!
The clap!
That's why I was like, why is she so familiar?
Yeah, the K-pop girl in Marvel Rivals.
Cause like she... The way she moves is just like her.
Cause like they both like glide.
Orbital Ray.
That's actually crazy.
She sends out a fucking ray from the sky.
Then she's like literally Luna Snow.
You're gonna see exactly what I mean.
That's why I scheduled Marvel... Well, to be fair.
That's why I scheduled Overwatch before Marvel Rivals.
So you can see the direct comparison between the two.
Cause that's... She even looks like her!
Like, it's like... Isn't that like...
Okay, to be fair, they both have like short hairstyle.
Like, it's so similar!
It's so similar.
Alright, so that is Juno!
Alright, let's check out... I downloaded somebody's gameplay too.
So we're gonna pretend.
I specifically looked for somebody who has like...
No commentary.
So we can like...
I'll pretend I'm playing.
Okay?
Just for you guys.
I'm gonna...
But this is... It's from this guy.
This guy has like... I think this video has like zero views or whatever.
Like, okay, sorry.
This video has two views and it's from me.
Um...
This guy... This is...
Guys, I'm playing Juno on the controller right now.
But... I thought I was... I just wanted to look at... I just wanted to see what the gameplay is like.
So you shoot to heal.
But yeah, huge shout out to that guy.
Literally, there was like three people with no commentary Juno gameplay.
Two of that gameplay was like in...
I think like...
I don't know what language it was in.
It was not English.
Like, I think it was like a European language.
I don't know.
I just... It was...
It was not in English.
So I was like, I'm gonna download an English gameplay.
I think she is projectile.
Oh my gosh, you can tell this is like fucking controller.
Oh,
okay.
So that heals everybody.
Okay, that's nice to know.
Oh, and then she has...
What is that?
What is that shield?
I can't tell what that shield is.
It's like you're shooting...
Okay, yeah, the super soaker.
Yeah, the controller turn.
Oh, the heals are really nice.
It's like super fast.
I don't know what the...
Is it speed ring?
Oh, it's a speed ring.
Okay, so when you're in the ring, you're faster.
That's really nice.
So like...
That's pretty good.
I think I like...
And then she like glides just like Mercy apparently.
Like her gliding.
Yeah, like I like how...
Like how...
Look how fast I...
Okay, look at your Orisa.
Heal your Orisa.
Okay, this healing is insane though.
I think the healing is insane.
The output for how fast it is.
I'm just like thinking like how fast would your heals be if you were in the speed ring in general.
If you're all in the speed ring.
And you just like...
If you're...
If you speed ring yourself to heal.
It seems like it could like save...
You can save somebody really fast from that.
No heal only DPS.
Yeah, her missiles.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
The missile heal is locked in.
Yeah, I noticed that too.
That's such a fast heal.
Holy shit.
In general.
And I like how it's locked in.
So like you don't have to...
You can like do the locked in missile and then like hide behind the wall right after.
Shoot the monkey!
Oh, okay.
Sorry, I can't.
Console players.
Just I don't know.
Console players has like a different meta.
Because I know a lot of console players play Torbjorn because they have...
They have like the extra turret.
So,
I'm going to be listening so close by.
DPS.
Only bass.
Have no excuse.
It feels strong.
But I feel like they're going nerf this.
That's not really so I didn't play it during the technical preview was their their have.
They were definitely in it.
This is he'll up to.
No.
Does it fly more?
This is the most round the fucking Juno I've ever seen.
You can tiltedly glide.
Oh!
Okay.
This is the speed, right?
Oh!
Wait, what?
Wait, it hits them too?
Wait, it heals and hits!
Wait, did you guys see that?
It heals, it heals and like hits people.
And DPS.
Wait, that's so good!
Wait, this fucking character is busted!
Yeah.
Yeah!
That's actually insane!
It heals and damages!
Because I saw the missiles hit the enemy team.
It heals and damage boosts.
It's good for... yeah, she seems like a...
That's what I'm saying!
Lucio's gonna be back in jail.
Back into baby jail you go, Lucio!
Nobody wants to... oh my god, that's counseling.
I wouldn't say busted, given the skill requirement.
Yeah, but in my elo, she's gonna be busted.
Like, yeah.
In my elo, she's gonna be so... like all the DPS players are gonna try and play her like how all the DPS players play Zarya.
Like... and Ana.
Yeah, good Juno would be terrible to play against.
Jeez.
Alright, I'm Juno-ing.
I'm Juno-ing right now.
Alright, Orisa, go in.
Go in.
I need you to engage with that Winston.
Sorry, I'm trying to immerse you guys right at the moment.
Lucio provides a steady speed boost.
Lucio has always been like super...
I think Juno might be more... what's the word?
Juno's gonna be more versatile in like what you can do with her.
Cause Lucio is very... what's the word?
Situational?
He's very situational cause right now, only people play Lucio for like Rein or Junker Queen.
That's like literally the only times I see Lucio being played.
But I feel like Juno works so much better.
It seems like for different tanks.
Lucio sucks, yeah, he's been in Lucio jail for a long time.
Usually only like Lucio one-tricks play Lucio.
Or you have a Junker Queen.
At least that doesn't go through.
Yeah, fuck this Mercy there.
At least like... uh...
At least like...
No, nevermind.
I was gonna say something good about Lucio, but he hasn't been good in a long time.
Hahahaha Hahahaha Hahahaha Yeah, I feel like... I like how like Bubbles work.
Like you can't heal through the Winston Bubbles.
How would you rework Lucio?
It's really hard to rework something when there's so many characters now.
I don't know how... I feel like... I don't know how League does it, but like it's always so hard to balance like characters the more...
Cause like, you know, the more supports you have like the more characters you have in certain roles, the harder it is to balance them to work for other... to make the other characters like work.
Because it's like...
Then you're gonna make Lucio too strong that he's gonna be a must pick.
And you don't... you don't want that.
You want to have people be able to counter swap.
Cause that's the whole thing.
Oh my god!
Okay!
I fucking... Okay!
I hate the new... hahaha I really hate...
Oh, poor guy.
Hahaha!
I hate... I really, really hate the tanks in Overwatch 2 now.
The current... I don't know!
Like for those who haven't played in a while, this is the current meta when it comes to Overwatch 2 for tank players.
And this is why nobody wants to play tank.
It's all about which tank counterswaps last.
I have had games...
Cause I've been playing this season.
Cause I want to end Top 500 this season.
I've been playing... Okay, so...
I'm playing Overwatch and like, literally, it's all...
Tanks are just counterswapping each other non-stop.
It was...
Hahaha!
Oh, that was the end.
Okay...
Hahaha!
That's literally it.
It's always tank swap until someone goes MAGA.
Hahaha!
Like, it's literally counterswaps, counterswaps, counterswaps, counterswaps, counterswaps, MAGA.
It's so annoying!
And then they would shit talk each other.
Cause whichever tank wins the counterswap battle, the winner of the counterswap battle would be like, fuck you for counterswapping.
And I'm like, you're both counterswapping!
Like, hahaha!
What are you... What are you...
You're both the problem!
Like... Hahaha!
Hahaha!
Like, what do you mean?
Like, ew!
It's...
This always happens!
They would yell at each other for counterswapping, and whoever wins shit talks the other tank and be like, shit player, keep counterswapping!
And I'm like, you're both doing it!
Hahaha!
Me and a genie want to play... No, that's a thing!
That's what tank is now!
I swear, I don't know if we're gonna experience it today, but this is literally what tanks are now.
It's literally non-stop counterswapping until somebody, like, until the last person who counterswaps at the end, which is... and wins.
The last counterswapper usually wins cause they don't have enough... cause the other tank does not have enough time to counterswap to win the game.
Like, it's always that!
It's so annoying!
It's... anyway, we're going into rank.
We've seen a lot about Juno then.
Um, it's awful.
It's so awful.
Like, I'm not...
as the person that's playing the support that's not on the tank role, it's so awful because...
cause I can't do anything about it.
Like...
Hahaha!
It's basically whoever knows how to play... yeah, it's who knows how to play the most tanks and, like, swaps the last.
It's so bad.
Hahaha!
Like, it's like nobody plays tank cause it's such a terrible experience.
Uh, like, I watched experiencing it and watching it as the support player is a fucking terrible experience.
I... I feel bad for the people playing it.
Hahaha!
For the tank players playing it.
It's not even...
It doesn't matter they're broken.
Like...
It just, you know...
It's just terrible.
It feels...
terrible cause then, you know, you lose because you don't know enough tanks.
You're not good enough at all the tanks so you lose.
Hahaha!
Yeah, he who swaps last usually... I'm not warmed up by the way so I haven't played Overwatch.
I know I said, like, I wanted to, like, practice, um...
I wanted to practice Overwatch.
Uh, cause I wanted to get... Oh my god.
Bro!
One... Let me 1v1!
I have to literally fight Doomfist!
Um...
I know I was like, I want to end top 500 for Overwatch this season, but I haven't played Overwatch in a bit, like, since a week so...
What the f- Oh my god!
Bro!
I'm fucking streaming!
Let me have this!
Oh wait, I forgot to give you guys audio.
It's alright.
It's fucking deathmatch.
Who cares?
Uh...
Alright, there we go.
It's literally deathmatch.
Who cares?
Alright, where's my lane?
See?
That's fucking right.
Reversal.
Bitch.
Oh!
What the fuck!
That's not right!
Oh my god!
Come on!
Let me have this!
Stupid Reaper.
Okay, I hate that...
I miss when Cassie didn't have, like, fall off.
So it feels good to shoot somebody.
Bro, that's fucked up.
No!
I missed the shot that matters!
Bro, that's fucked up!
Where are they?
They're up in the house.
Oh.
Where did they all go?
I don't wanna be...
What?
Oh!
Yeah, thank you.
Thanks.
Hahaha!
Save!
Yay!
Bro!
No!
Hahaha!
It's okay.
I got...
Yay!
I'm first with my one kill!
Hahaha!
The Plumacy wins again.
That's nice.
No!
He's literally one!
Pick your goddamn head!
Pick your head!
That's fucking right!
I thought so.
I fucking thought so.
Bro!
Oh shit!
I'm sorry.
Hahaha!
What the fuck?
What was I on?
What the fuck was I...
I was like gliding a bit.
Ero, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Overwatch, hi Toki, love you lots.
Overwatch sucks but we still play it.
It's cause like...
There's like literally no game right now.
There's literally like nothing.
It's like either for us fucking like fast movement shooters.
I mean not fast, like moderate speed.
Hahaha!
Cause tactical shooters fast.
Um... There's nothing we can...
There's nothing to play for us.
Is it really Overwatch or Apex?
Cause then like Call of Duty is way too fast.
Like... I guess like...
Time to... Time to explode.
Time to kill.
All we do... Have you heard of Concord?
Yeah, I heard his dog shit.
Hahaha!
Like I don't know what you want me to say.
That's literally what I heard.
That's... Concord.
Same.
And apparently COD sucks now too.
Everything sucks.
We're just miserable.
We're just miserable players now.
Hahaha!
Fuck you.
I just wanna kill this one guy.
What the fuck!
That's fucked up!
I saw you guys as friends!
Miserable but addicted.
We're miserable players.
We're just miserable.
There's nothing else to do.
Haha!
Except for Overwatch or Apex.
Cause nothing... We like nothing.
We don't deserve joy.
Hahaha!
That's fucking right.
This is fucked up.
This is... What!
Why did you come over here!
Hahaha!
This is...
FPS is dying.
We have nothing left.
That's why Marvel...
I feel like... I don't know.
TPS as well.
I don't really find too much joy in TPS.
But I like... I enjoy Marvel Rivals.
I think Marvel Rivals just scratches the itch for an Overwatch player.
A lot of like ex-Overwatch players are playing Marvel Rivals right now too.
The fucking goddamn Overwatch League.
The ex-Overwatch League players 6-stack.
Wait is this a 6-stack?
It's a 6-stack right?
For Marvel Rivals?
Yeah.
The ex-Overwatch League players 6-stack that was top 10 or top 20.
I swear.
If you guys saw Marvel Rivals leaderboards for the close alpha, it was all...
It was all Overwatch players.
Ex-Overwatch players.
Or current Overwatch players.
All of them were like ex-Overwatch pros.
And they just hogged the top 20 because that's all they play.
Instead of Overwatch.
Yeah.
It scratches the itch for us.
It's like...
Overwatch skills transfers over to...
Overwatch skills transfers over to Marvel Rivals even though it's TPS.
It's literally the same thing.
Except different POV.
Blade, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
No, it's just...
I'm in the deathmatch which is like waiting for your match to start lobby.
So even they were stream sniping, they were just stream sniping my deathmatch lobby.
So they also are suffering because they are queueing for rank.
Because you have to queue for rank to get into those lobbies.
.
So like, we're all suffering because they are going to play rank too.
So...
It's so real.
It's fine.
Oh my god.
Why do you play Pharah?
Because then I have to go meta and fucking go...
No!
Okay, I'll do one life.
Because I...
This fucker wants to play Pharah.
I wanna play fucking Zen.
It's fun.
Zen is fun.
Zarya, what are you doing?
Zarya!
I think he got knocked off.
Oh.
Alright.
Well...
Oh, they're playing Sigma.
I wasn't gonna play fucking Zenyatta anyway.
Dude, this Ekko is farming the shit out of me.
Alright guys, time for some...
Time for some Zzz's.
.
Time to play meta.
It's pharmacy time!
Yay!
Woo!
Pharmacy!
.
Zzz!
Yay!
Pharah, get the fuck off!
Pharah!
Oh, I don't think this Pharah knows I'm not there.
Goodbye.
Oh wait, I saved his life.
You're welcome.
Please, at least kill the...
Please.
Oh god, thank you.
Yeah, the thing is this Ekko does not have a Mercy Pocket.
So, we win automatically because of it.
Alright.
Goodbye Pharah.
If you die, you die.
Pharah, no!
I'm not with you!
You don't have a Pocket!
Come... Okay, there you go.
We're fine.
It's alright.
This Pharah plays as if he has a Pocket.
That's when you know.
Pharah... Yeah, Pharah can barely fly.
They changed something about her.
So, like...
Uh...
Oh god.
See, I told... That's fucking fair.
That's Pharah, bro.
Barely one hit.
That's fucking Pharah.
No!
Pharah doesn't need... Oh, well somebody better tell this Pharah.
This Pharah is fucking playing as if he needs a Pocket right now.
Like, look at...
He's fucking playing like he needs a Pocket.
Because he's so hyper aggressive.
Like, no Ana is going to be able to heal you like that.
You're playing out of LOS.
Winston, bro.
I don't know why he's playing Zarya too.
This is the whole Overwatch experience.
Pharah, please swap so I can play a better game.
So I can enjoy my game.
I...
Oops.
Time to leave.
What?
Okay.
Oh my god!
What is going on?
Alright.
Goodbye, Zarya.
I mean, I could rez.
And then die for it?
Question mark?
No, Ana, I'm sorry.
You just gotta die.
Wait, unless...
Okay, nice.
Okay, Zarya, I...
I don't know, Zarya.
Zarya, why are you there?
How did you get there?
Zarya, how the fuck How the fuck...
Somebody push the car!
Okay.
How did he get there?
For the greater good.
How the fuck did he get there, though?
Oh no, he went...
Oh no, he has Sigma.
I'm gonna not be there.
Because he still has Sigma.
Oh.
Here it is.
Am I gonna get pulled?
Oh shit.
What the fuck!
Where did he...
Okay.
Alright.
I don't know where he Sigma ulted, by the way.
I...
I have no idea where the Sigma ult went.
I just watched the Sigma fly for 20 years and then Echo appeared?
Echo?
No.
Goddammit.
It's fine.
Got it.
Let this Zarya.
There we go.
Kill the Ilari.
Kill Ilari.
He's not healing.
He's just DPSing.
Alright.
There we go.
I have no idea where the fuck the Echo came from.
Oh, thank god.
Are you swapping?
Please.
Let me enjoy the game!
Also, I found Elk.
I don't know if you guys know this change.
I did not know this change, because this was not in the old Overwatch rank system.
But you gotta win 50 games now.
In the past, you had to play...
You had to play 50 games.
Oh my god.
I heard it.
Yeah, you have to win 50 games, which I think is... Oh my god.
Please.
Leave me alone.
I thought that was a bullshit change.
I wonder like... Jesus, goodbye.
Alright.
To defeat a Rein, it's time to swap.
I swear to god.
Swap.
Pharah, I'm not gonna pocket you anymore.
Can we Ilari?
Okay.
Alright.
Alright, let's go.
I don't know why you wanted Ilari, but...
Wait, where?
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god.
Okay.
It doesn't help that like, you know...
Shit, I forgot.
That was not the pylon.
I wanted to use the pylon.
You can tell I have not played Ilari, because I never needed to.
I never needed to play Ilari.
Woo!
Goodbye.
Hahaha.
Woo!
Alright.
I can't put the pylon.
No pylon, guys.
I don't know why you guys want me to play Ilari, but okay.
I'm trying to help him.
Oh my god, he's so low.
He's actually so low.
Wait, he's Ilari?
Why?
I guess for the ult?
I'll put it on the cart.
There we go.
Please!
Keep the Cassidy up!
Oh, what?!
I'm behind the p-
That's crazy!
Okay, I have ult, though.
Oh!
Wee!
Nice.
It's fine.
We got the Hanzo ult.
And then I can Ilari ult this.
I'll put it on here.
Nice.
Cruisy.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
I'll put it here.
Hahaha.
Wait, what?
Yay!
I was gonna say, where the fuck do I use this?
They all dead.
They're all dead!
Yay!
We're doing good!
That's all that matters.
Alright, now I wanna play Jinara.
Nice.
It's okay, I blocked the door.
I don't think anybody was going there, but I blocked the door, guys.
Alright.
Guys!
I don't think anybody was there!
But like...
I blocked the possibility!
That's all that matters!
I heard they got...
They got rid of...
They're getting rid of gold guns.
I heard.
Anyway, now that I'm not corporate, I can say that people are planning on... It's so fucked up.
It's like the Pink Mercy black market, but people are planning on buying gold guns for like... uh...
Because like... we get legacy coins.
Legacy competitive coins.
And...
uh... people are planning on like...
hoarding their legacy competitive coins to buy like...
new character gold guns.
So it's gonna be even rarer to find like gold guns for newer characters.
So people are planning on like selling accounts with like Juno gold guns because it's gonna be really rare to get it.
Because like...
not a lot of people save their competitive coins.
Because I'm not a gold gun.
I save them.
But like...
Because I didn't have any character I wanted to... Are you fair again?
Oh my god.
I was not paying attention.
I was not paying attention clearly.
Oh, they're running Zarya.
I don't like that.
Okay, I'm gonna put...
Oh my god.
Alright, fine.
Cool.
Okay.
Where is Zarya?
I need to fucking swap.
Nice.
Oh my god.
I don't... I hate... I hate babying a DPS.
If I'm not like duo with them.
Because you don't have communication.
Like if they wanna... It's so hard... It's not hard but it's so annoying to pocket somebody if you don't use comms for the pocket.
It's just not as fun.
You know?
He's dead.
Don't worry.
I got you!
Because it's... Obviously it's easier to pocket when you know...
When you know when they need it.
Yeah, you have to predict them.
Jesus, this echo.
This fucking echo.
I love to juggle my orbs so much.
Oh.
They're just poking our Zarya.
They're not What the fuck is this Sombra?
I don't like it.
Oh, she almost has Zarya ult that fast?
Holy shit.
You have orb!
I don't know what you want from me!
I need to pay attention.
So... Like right now.
Ooh.
Get over here.
There you go.
You're welcome!
I saved your life!
Oh shit fam!
I will pop ult!
Don't worry!
I got you!
Get away!
That's right!
Get away from my eyes!
I'll pick your ass!
Alright.
It's alright.
She's alive.
Supporting carry.
My Ana is really good.
I really like my Ana.
She's like... She's landing her sleeps unlike me.
God.
This Sombra is looking for her ult.
I can tell.
Just scary.
I can tell that...
Oh god.
I can tell that she's looking for a Sombra ult right now.
Which is very scary!
Because...
I don't know...
No way!
Oh god.
I lived.
But it doesn't matter.
I lived though.
He has ult!
He has... Zyrean please!
Zyrean please!
Please I can't kick that away!
I can tell!
It actually hit me!
No!
I failed the Sombra ult too!
I was like...
This is it.
Okay I'm going to go Lucio.
We can still...
Oh my god.
Sorry.
My sense for Lucio was so high.
And I was not used to it.
It's not used to it.
Oh no.
Can we touch it?
Yes!
No!
We were so close to touching it!
I forgot I have a super high sense on Lucio.
Because I haven't played Lucio in a long time.
Like...
I...
I have not played... like... not... you know...
I haven't played Lucio in a long time.
I was like...
Because this high sense...
disoriented me so hard.
Uh...
The high sense really disoriented me.
Oh no.
No!
You got me good!
It's still winnable though.
We just need to reset.
We are super staggered.
I might have to use my res to...
un-stagger us.
Alright.
Time to babysit the Pharah.
Hello Pharah.
Your babysitter is here.
Oh my god.
Well...
Okay.
That was like on him.
Honestly.
I don't know what that guy expected.
Like...
Honestly.
Oh!
This is where I die I think.
Here you go Cassidy.
Like...
I don't know.
I'm trying to figure it out too.
Are you serious?
Oh my god!
Did I get solo ulti?
Like what?
Holy shit!
I...
Push over!
What the fuck?
I actually got this guy!
I was promised Juno's not even available!
Okay I'm gonna fucking have to swap off.
And then I guess they really want me to play Lari.
Bro you were on Pharah!
What the fuck do you mean?
I was literally...
Okay.
This is as defensive as I can get.
You literally went fucking...
W key so hard!
It's not our fault you W...
Oh god Zarya please.
I just wanna use this so we can...
Resituate.
We're gonna use this to fucking resituate so I can swap off.
Please.
Kill one person so it matters.
Oh okay.
I mean he wasted his ult.
So like that's good.
Okay this... Watch this Cassidy die in front of me.
Guys I don't know guys.
This is...
Not the best idea right now.
Alright.
Okay.
Using that Lucio to go straight in!
Alright!
This is where I die!
I touched it!
Your turn!
It's just...
Why do we still have a Zarya?
Why?
This is what I mean!
It's just counter tank!
They went monkey!
It's free D.Va hours!
It's literally free D.Va!
Bro!
It's literally free D.Va pick!
It's literally the freest D.Va pick you can get!
Okay you just gotta... guys.
Alright.
You're a great Zarya player but you don't counterswap.
I can't.
I need a counterswap tank.
I need a tank that knows how to counterswap.
That's really it.
She's good but like...
Not against Winston!
Winston!
Jesus you're fu- I don't care.
You die you still touch.
Please stop!
And you just didn't want to touch!
Oh my god!
He's a good Zarya player!
But like... if we had a Winston during the last defense it would've been easier.
We literally needed uh... we literally needed D.Va for that last part.
Oh my god why?
Okay I would've played...
Jesus Christ.
Juggling of orbs is so f***ing difficult sometimes.
Okay.
Well he's Rein so that's easier.
I know a lot of people were playing Ilari though now.
Okay.
Is our Ana okay?
Okay as long as our Ana is okay.
Nice!
I'm juggling orbs right now!
Play f***ing juggler!
Alright.
What the f*** is going on?
I'm amazed you got 13 devs?
Oh my god.
To be fair both DPS has 13 devs so it's like...
I don't want to...
I think our Faerie might die unless we...
Nice okay.
We did it.
But they literally have one fight so like I'm trying to make sure that...
Yep okay nevermind.
Okay.
They might push with that now.
Alright.
Trying to...
Juggling the orb!
Juggling the orb right now!
Oh god.
I can't f***ing get...
Damage in.
Because of that stupid Rein shield.
Alright.
Backing up!
Oh.
What?
Nice!
That's good for us!
Alright.
Nice.
I can trans this.
Didn't need it.
Alright.
There we go.
Stay alive!
STAY ALIVE!
STAY ALIVE ANA!
Okay we're fine.
That's fine.
There's somebody to my left.
They have shatter though.
Like 100%.
And...
Oh!
Good luck.
They have shatter so like...
A little scared about it.
Oh nice.
Oh but...
Thanks.
Okay.
Please stay alive.
No I can't die with the life!
Wait is it Ana?
No it's Mei and Ana.
Okay.
Oh god.
Oh god sorry.
Please.
Please Mei.
Mei please.
Please our pharaoh is coming at me!
Oh no I'm getting fucking shot at by...
I'm getting shot at by Lari!
What do you mean?
You don't seep!
I give you one free take!
Oh my god.
Jesus Christ!
What the fuck is going on?
Here we go.
I...
Really these two...
What the fuck is going on?
Oh my god.
Die on cart.
Who made pro IGL?
Jesus!
This is dysfunctional.
Bro this is my first game!
What the fuck is going on?
Oh my god.
I know it was a good idea.
If they have...
I feel like Zen would be a better pick just for the...
Just for the orbs.
But like...
More healing goes in.
This Ana is really good.
I like this Ana though.
This Ana has had really good...
Really good decision making.
Quiet now.
Oh shit!
Holy fuck!
Oh that sniper is nice.
We're fine.
Jesus Christ.
There you go.
I'm just going for the kill.
I'm just going for the extra heals at this point.
Oh my god.
People are so mad!
I think the extra heals was a good decision.
Nice.
Our Ashe is good too.
Oh shit!
Yeah we have a good Ashe.
I hope you have Ice Block!
Okay you do.
Okay nice.
Don't worry Ana I got you.
I got you Ana.
And I got you too.
Okay this Ashe is actually carrying us.
There you go.
I don't want you to die.
You're not gonna die on me Ashe!
You're literally the carry!
Alright.
Don't worry I got you.
I have ult too.
I might not be DPSing.
But you're all alive.
And that's all that matters right now in this game.
What?!
He died so fast.
Okay we just...
Oh we did not...
Alright Ana we leave.
Ana we leave.
Ana Ana Ana.
We can recontest this together.
We have ults to recontest this.
Oh my god shut the fuck up!
Our Ashe was carrying!
Shut the fuck up!
We have a good Ashe!
Alright.
Oh okay.
Oh that was...
That was a bad move but okay.
Alright sorry it's you and me.
Sorry I wish you did not take that though.
Sorry.
Why did you take that?
Sorry!
Why did you take the heal?
Oh my god.
Sorry I should not have taken the heals.
But that's okay.
That's okay.
Oh my god.
I don't know why I got an ult.
But okay.
Oh.
I need to make sure our fucking Ashe lives though.
At this rate.
We got pick?
I think?
Why?
I might be dead.
Ana heal me here?
I'm here.
Zarya please.
Oh they have Zarya.
Grab two.
Do we have ult?
We do.
We have ult for the last time.
Last fight.
I'm trying.
I'm literally sacrificing.
I sacrificed my life for this.
So I hope they do something with it.
Oh my god.
Please.
Literally Ilaria is one.
Ilaria is one.
Oh god please.
Oh no.
Just freeze in there.
Oh god.
Oh god please.
Please.
I'm trying to kick you up.
As long as I can.
Please.
I'm literally trying so hard.
Oh god.
Please.
I kept you guys up for so long.
Guys I think my team.
Fell apart.
I think my team fell apart.
Oh my god.
My team was a mess.
I'm gonna avoid both the DPS.
I'm gonna avoid these two.
These two should not be together.
Oh my god.
These two.
This guy and this guy.
They cannot be together.
Our fucking.
Ashe was so fucking good too.
Oh my god.
These two.
Our Zarya needed a fucking swap.
He still played Zarya until the very end.
He was a great Zarya.
But like holy.
He should have swapped out.
Our Ana was insane.
Our Ana was really good.
Our Ashe was really good too.
But these two.
These two were just.
They were not meant to be together.
They were oil and water.
They did not.
Deserve to play together.
Holy fuck.
I don't know what else.
Our Ana, Ashe and I could do.
We were literally trying so hard.
They were so.
They were so committed.
They were.
They were so fucking.
I just wish he wasn't on fucking Zarya the entire time.
Literally.
Literally did not need to play Zarya.
Oh okay.
If he swapped out Zarya.
We could have won.
If he was D.Va.
That was such a D.Va victory.
I think we had D.Va.
There for the last fight.
The last fight before.
During the stall.
We could have won that.
Oh no it's deathmatch guys.
So like game practice.
Because I need it.
Oh my god.
That was intense though.
You might have stunned me but it doesn't matter.
I better aim.
Yeah.
Because that counter is Winston.
That would have been a good D.Va pick.
Oh.
Okay.
I keep forgetting that stuns.
That doesn't do anything.
I missed the stun.
You can still shoot when you are Cassidy.
Uh.
Thrown.
Oh.
No.
My two kills.
My fucking two kill lead.
Oh.
There is something to my side.
Unless it's just the...
Oh.
Fucking nerd.
Play more Tekken get the chance?
If it was another tournament.
Yeah.
I don't think I can play Tekken as like a regular thing.
I don't think I can be like an FGC streamer in general.
Oh hey there is that guy again.
Well at least we know he will play Zarya.
At least we know.
Let's see.
What is our other guy gonna play?
Oh attack.
Oh.
Okay I can play.
Darkblade thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Since you are talking about TPS what about Splatoon?
Splatoon is dead in the west.
The only games you are gonna get in Splatoon are people in Japan.
You know he is a good Zarya.
He just didn't swap.
Like he is not a bad player.
And also he was like.
He and the TPS player were just shit talking each other.
Despite how much I love Splatoon.
It's a dead game in the west.
Nobody in the west really plays it.
And even then.
It's like the pro players in Splatoon.
Are like.
They don't.
They don't like even make enough money to survive.
Alright.
Yep there he is.
There is the Zarya.
There he is.
Oh Echo I hope you peek me.
I hope you peek me Echo.
Nice.
Oh I just realized.
We have a Rein.
We have a fucking Rein.
I just realized that.
Alright.
That is unlucky for us.
Because usually.
I mean the enemy team last game had a Rein swap.
But like.
Usually.
Yeah.
I'm not feeling confident with the Rein.
No I might be dead.
Please don't let this guy kill me.
Please don't try.
Jesus.
He is going to have grav soon.
All he is doing is farming grav.
Where is he?
I'm gonna.
Please.
Do something.
With that Echo.
Did he do something with that?
That one.
Alright.
That is at least one bubble gone.
He has grav 100%.
I can tell.
I'm so bad at sleeps now.
No.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Thanks so much.
When I'm playing Ana.
I forgot.
Why are you still on Rein?
Please.
I wish you were not still on Rein.
I wish.
Please.
Pick me.
Don't pick the bomb.
Why are you still Rein?
He is dead.
I don't know why he went that way.
Okay.
That's good.
Zarya.
Come on.
Where is Zarya?
Oh god.
No.
Well.
I'm not gonna use my ult there.
Alright.
They still holding grav.
Oh.
Thank god.
Alright.
We are gonna die to grav.
Guys.
You wanna watch us die to grav?
Watch this.
That's huge.
Yeah.
That actually is huge.
I... I... I...
You pick me.
That's actually huge for us.
I need you guys to not be so far away from me.
I need to be away from the Zarya too.
Oh.
Thank god.
Thank god the Zarya was super...
I was not looking when I fucking threw that.
Alright.
Time to B.
Cry bitch.
Please don't die.
I'm cart bitch.
Oh.
Whoa.
Okay.
Oh.
Alright.
Please don't die.
Zarya.
Oh.
Miss.
Fuck.
I thought he was gonna go back.
I didn't think he would keep going forward.
After all of that.
I don't know.
It felt like logical.
That he would go back.
Oh.
Backwards?
I don't.
Doesn't that feel logical?
Alright.
Try to do some.
You know.
I thought they would be closer.
Too.
This is not logical.
It's okay.
They wasted an ult.
Alright.
I'll die.
I thought they'd be pushing out!
I predict... that was a bad prediction from me.
Because they did not do what I thought.
I had a bad prediction.
Because I legitimately thought he was gonna, you know... move up.
I thought he was gonna move back after getting hit.
And I thought the enemy team was gonna push us.
Also, they're still holding Grav for last fight.
So, I don't know.
I should've went Kiriko.
I'm gonna see if I can swap to Kiriko in time.
Oh no, Pharah.
No, Pharah.
No.
They're still...
Oh, what?
Alright, goodbye.
It's fine, we got the cart!
Okay.
I'm gonna go Kiriko for the fucking Zarya Grav.
He still has ult?
Like...
How does he still have ult?
I've been having bad predictions, though.
I don't know.
They're not doing the things I think they're doing.
Because you would assume, since we're so close to the point that they would push up...
Because they're five.
But they didn't do it.
So, like, I don't know.
Like, I'm so confused.
I...
I'm just...
I'm trying to use logic.
But there's no logic.
There's no logic!
Are they gonna ult yet?
Ult here!
Come on, Zarya!
This is so smart to do!
Ult here?
What are you...
What are you gonna ult?
I don't understand!
Good luck.
Wait!
Still no ult?
Oh, god.
Still no ult, by the way!
Huge pick.
I don't know.
There you go.
I cleansed it.
Oh, my god!
There it is!
It got no button!
What?
Okay.
I'm gonna...
It got nobody, but there it is!
So!
There it is!
Holy shit!
Go, girl!
Give us nothing!
Oh, my god!
This is a D1, the Master's Five game!
You could have done it, like, 20 times, Zarya!
How many years ago?
I don't understand.
Now we know why they...
They had like 20 alts last game.
And like... I don't understand.
I don't understand anymore.
With a huge grab into nothing!
I feel like if they're gonna run Ana again, I'm gonna go Kiriko.
This is like the only reason to go Kiriko.
Also like, I feel like...
I don't know.
I feel like these guys are way too aggressive.
Just too busy typing team chat?
Bro, okay, avoiding that guy was a good decision.
It was a good idea.
Instead of avoiding the Zarya.
Yeah, I know.
Oh my god.
That was so embarrassing.
That was so embarrassing for that Zarya.
Literally...
Literally held that all for...
Fucking...
700 fights.
My predictions didn't work because they had no logic in the way they play.
Oh my god.
I mean, you could tell he was a one trick Zarya.
Like...
It was not rocket science.
Because he's...
Oh.
I'm scared, but...
Don't worry.
I'm here.
Okay, maybe worry a little bit?
Maybe worry...
I need to keep the Rematra alive though.
Yeah, I can't focus on our Ilari because our Rematra...
Our tank is much more important.
I'm so sorry, Lari.
I shot that guy once.
And I think that caused it.
That one shot.
That one shot that got you low.
Sorry.
Sorry, buddy.
You know, fuck it.
I mean, I have ult right now.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh!
Yeah, you did!
This is where we leave our team.
Goodbye, mate.
Goodbye.
With loose tank, we leave.
That's how we do things.
Please, keep arguing with your team!
The Genji has ult, though.
100%.
I hope he targets me and I have fucking, like, uh...
What's it called?
I have TP.
So, and then the team is not with me.
That's like the most optimal plan to get rid of.
He should be close to...
He should be close to another Grav.
Come on!
Give us something, Zarya!
Come on, Zarya!
Kill him!
Woah!
Kill the Zarya!
How is he still alive?!
How the fuck...
Okay, he has no energy, but he definitely has Grav.
Alright.
He definitely still has Grav.
But we do have a Matra ult, so he could, like, absorb.
I need to make sure I'm not near.
They have Grav Blade!
I think they're gonna use that as a combo.
Most likely.
I'm not wasting a sleep.
I'll be fine.
Oh, god.
They're pushing up.
They have Nano Blade!
There it is!
Goodbye.
Oh.
There you go.
This is how you do it!
Oh, I don't have cleanse, though.
I don't have cleanse.
I don't have cleanse, Alari.
This is how we do it!
And that's how you play support when they have Nano Blade!
That's the strat!
That's the Nano Blade strat.
Huge.
Alright, I have... I'm gonna stay here, just in case.
Damn, what a fucking play.
That's what I mean!
When you're Kiriko and they have Nano Blade, you get away from your team, hope the Genji fucking tries to Blade you, TP to the other side, climb a wall, and then TP back.
Yeah, he's... 1-1-1-1-1.
Nice.
That's fucking right.
Get over here, Lucio!
So just bait him.
Yeah.
Nice job.
Also, if you have, like, Suzu... you have to have your Suzu.
I hate Smurfskr.
Who the fuck is Smurfing?
Darn Smurfs.
You sure it's Smurfs?
I have a fucking, like... what is it?
Gold account.
Bro, this guy is on fucking... Mei.
His name is Smurf, yeah.
Alright, nice.
That's how you do it.
Thank God.
Yay!
Almost Master IV.
I think it's Support.
Leaderboard... okay.
Um... it is currently...
Uh...
What is it currently for Support?
It is... Masters II!
I mean, that's doable.
I still need to win 50 games.
I do not have 50 wins yet.
Yay!
I don't really need a reason to have another account.
Honestly.
Uh...
I can just grind on this account.
That's the thing.
You have to... uh...
I just avoid... I mostly avoid tank players now.
It's like, when you have a bad tank, like, it changes everything.
Like, you just lose.
Like...
And like, they could be like the best tank in the world!
But if they only play one character!
They are fucking dog shit.
If they literally have...
If they can only play one tank, they're dog shit.
It doesn't matter if they're like the best tank at that tank in the world.
If it's just one tank, then there's no point.
Because... oh no, not Skirmish.
Please, not Skirmish.
I don't want to be in Skirmish.
Skirmish people just say hello to each other.
Hello!
Um... oh.
The moment I said that...
I'm so sorry.
Hello.
I'm a Hammond one trick, you're part of the problem.
Incredible timing.
Alright.
Who the fuck is playing Rein?
In my deathmatch.
Oh my god, this is worse!
The Doom was the worst pick.
Are you trying to hammer me?
That's fucking right.
That's fucking...
That's what you get.
Oh shit!
This is my hero.
No, no no no no.
No!
Oh my god...
You guys still died to him.
That's fucked up.
Please.
Please, don't come after me.
Please, if I don't shoot you.
If I don't shoot you, you won't shoot me.
I just.
I don't.
I do not want to deal...
NOOOOOO!
Please!
I don't really understand the emotions.
Alright.
Oh god.
Okay, one of the tanks is still there.
I swear to god, I will bully the shit out of this Rein player if he fucks with me again.
Oh my god!
Is he protecting the Cassidy?!
What?!
Okay!
Fuck this!
That is so fucked up!
That is so... wait!
He act... oh my god!
I'm gonna...
Did you fuck this Rein?
He actually fucking...
blocked for the...
blocked for the Cassidy!
This fucker.
This actual fucker.
That's fucking...
Yeah!
That's a kill!
That's fuck... I become the tank player.
I...
Oh shit.
Whoops.
Bam.
I become the tank player!
That's fucking right!
He did this to me!
Oh.
That's not what I wanted, but that's fine.
I wouldn't have done this, but I became the villain.
I'm fucking cringe.
I became...
I become the cringe.
Ha!
That's right, Becky!
Remember what you did, Becky!
Oh.
Wait, is he gone?
Oh, he's gone.
He's gone.
Yeah, that's right.
Get back here.
That's fucking right!
Get back here!
No!
Everybody's tank now!
I created a monster.
Not everybody's tank.
My bad.
I created a monster, guys.
There's so many...
I've ruined the lobby.
I've ruined this lobby.
I made everybody go tank.
They all deserve it!
The cycle continues.
I created a cycle.
Alright.
I need to know what tank we're playing.
Okay.
We're not gonna have enough heals.
I was gonna play Zenyatta, but...
When everyone is cringe, No one else will be true.
No one else will be true.
Oh shit!
Wait!
Grandmaster tank?
Alright.
We have a Grandmaster tank now.
Nice!
Where the fuck are you here?
That means he was GM last season.
Does it take longer to class?
Oh, it should because like...
There's not enough Grandmasters right now.
Yeah, I'm streamer mode, so my name is different every game.
I only do that because I don't want to...
I don't want people to throw purposely.
So that's why.
What?
I thought that would hit.
I need to reload.
I'm just surprised that didn't hit.
Somebody...
No!
What?
How did that not hit?
I'm surprised that didn't hit.
Not gonna lie.
I'm just throwing sleeps randomly.
That's not good.
Oh god!
Oh god.
Sigma, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
Sigma.
Oh, please!
I'm getting juggled!
I'm getting juggled right now!
I'm a mess!
Okay, I'm okay.
I'm okay.
I need to practice my sleeps.
I have not been doing good sleeps.
Already?
He's dead.
Please, he's one.
He's literally one.
Please, Sombra.
Shoot him!
I need to practice my...
Wait, where has our Soldier been?
Not gonna lie.
Where is our Soldier?
I've not seen our Soldier this entire fight.
I...
I feel like I haven't seen our Soldier at all.
Alright, he's dead.
Alright, there you go.
They have Junkrat Tire.
100%.
Please!
We can't peek!
Oh, okay.
I'm swapping.
We need Kiriko.
Where has our Soldier been doing?
I swear, I've not seen our Soldier at all.
I'll find my own path.
How's your Grandmaster doing?
He's getting fucking bullied.
That's what's happening.
There's like so many fucking juggling aspects.
Like, they still have Tire.
Did they buff Ilari?
Oh, he's so low!
Did they buff her?
Cause everybody's playing her right now.
Oh.
Goodbye.
We're here.
Don't worry, we can adjust!
Right?
Alright, Ilari.
You can kill him, right?
Oh, that's why everybody's playing Ilari.
Okay.
That makes a lot more sense.
I was like, did she get buffed?
Truly a hurt people hurt people moment.
Not so deadpool.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What the fuck is... that's a good question.
This is... our team is not playing together.
And...
Oh, Pharah-Junkrat combo.
Wait, is that actually meta?
I haven't been playing for a week.
And they made Junkrat...
Fuck.
Junkrat-Phera meta?
Really?
They changed... literally I played a week ago.
And this was not meta.
Oh my god.
I did not realize...
So many things changed in one week.
Literally stop playing for a week and this happens.
This sucks.
Now I have to learn Ilari.
This fucking sucks.
Alright.
Oh, both our DPS is dead.
I'm gonna go back to the game.
Both our DPS is dead.
Alright.
Okay.
I don't...
Alright.
You know what?
We don't need...
We don't need our DPS.
Oh no.
The one trap.
The one fucking giant series.
I'm so unlucky.
I didn't see it.
Are you serious?
I'm so unlucky.
Oh my god.
Truly...
There's no way.
He farmed that fucking...
He has been hammering our hog this entire fight.
There's no way he does not have...
Oh, alright.
Guess I heal our DPS now too.
Nice.
Alright.
Oh, there's the ult.
There's the ult.
I'm fucking making sure I'm not with them.
There it is.
There he is.
What?
How?
How does that hit me?
How does that...
Oh god.
I'm staying up here.
I'm in my safe zone.
Get in there.
Keep stalling.
I'm in my safe zone.
Oh, hi.
He's on me, but it's okay.
Because we're still alive.
Hog, we're still alive.
That's okay.
Oh, what a fucking hook.
No.
What a fucking hook.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god!
Please!
Me and the hide.
The dream team.
I'm literally doing so much.
What do you mean?
Please clutch up.
I'm surviving.
You're fine.
I can't believe they have tire.
They have tire and they're so close.
What is our DPS doing?
That's the better question.
I feel like our DPS is non-existent.
It's just hogging me.
Oh my god.
Bro, he's one.
Oh, the headshot though.
Did you guys see the headshot?
Bro, is this the first fucking soldier ult I've seen today?
Is this the first fucking soldier ult I've seen today?
Oh my god.
They're doing their best.
Just me and the hog.
The hog and I literally survived so much.
Oh my god.
Bro, our fucking Ilari has worked damage at the other DPS.
He's doing the work.
It's your turn to die.
I'm gonna lock in.
What the fuck is...
Oh, it's our Symmetra.
No, our Symmetra.
Jesus Christ.
Our soldier and Symmetra have not existed.
I swear.
I've not seen them.
Oh my god.
I'm glad I picked Kiriko.
That Kiriko pick was actually...
No way!
No fucking way!
I can't believe it.
Nice.
Oh, hog.
Me and the hog!
Back at it again!
Keep the hog alive!
This is the...
Keep hog alive!
Save the hog!
Save the world!
Literally it.
Actually getting hard carried by the hog right now.
Oh, he's so close to dying too.
I almost killed him.
Nice.
Don't worry, I got you!
I won't get trapped this time!
That's fucking right!
That's right!
Keep hog alive!
Me and the hog!
Dynamic duo!
I like his new kit.
I actually like the...
What was it?
The grid nade.
Oh my god, he went hog.
He went hog!
Oh my god!
He's so engi.
He went Zenyatta!
Oh my god, this is hard hog counter.
Oh my god, he went Zenyatta!
Jesus Christ!
Oh my god!
That's fucked up.
That's so fucked up.
Oh my god, that's so fucked up!
Oh, that is so fucked up.
I didn't do this because I got scared I was gonna get hooked.
I got scared.
Okay.
No hook.
No hook, we're fine.
He actually went full hog counter.
That's actually scary as hell.
That's fine.
Yeah!
Oh my god!
Okay, that's a little overkill but I'm fine with that.
I'm fine with that.
That was a little overkill.
Be afraid.
The fucking Kiriko ult.
Oh, I thought that was the trap.
The Kiriko ult.
Hog ult for that one guy.
The hog player.
That poor...
Oh my god, our Soldier did it!
He gave us something!
He got a killer!
He...
He still has Junkrat ult.
He hasn't Junkrat ulted at all once.
Oh my god.
He gave us something!
A win is a win.
I'm gonna GG hog.
You carried.
I'm giving a compliment.
Play of the day.
I know!
He's like, yep.
It's him.
He's so humble.
He knows.
That was a... yeah that felt like an uphill battle.
It was me and the hog against the world.
That 100% was...
That felt like an uphill battle.
That's me.
No, no.
He deserved that.
Oh my god.
Our DPS literally was non-existent.
Our hog literally won v4'd everybody.
Non-stop.
It was crazy.
He literally won v4'd.
Oh this is a new lobby.
That's fucking right.
You tried to...
Widow me?
That's fucking right.
You tried to tracer me?
The Soldier Sim was actually wild though.
Oh okay.
I killed both of them so they two-timed.
They double teamed.
That...
You know I deserved that.
I 100% deserved that.
I killed both of them individually so they teamed up.
Is he on D.Va?
Who hurt him?
Oh I did not mean to...
I did not mean to right click.
It was a mis-input.
Alright.
Widow.
Nice try.
Nice try tracer.
Okay!
Am I 1v5?
Is this a 1v5?
I'm like...
They all came after me?
How the fuck was I supposed to kill...
3 people back to back to back with no heals?
That was fucked up.
That was actually fucked up.
I'm gonna help you.
Just fuck this D.Va.
Fuck this D.Va in particular.
Actually...
Fuck this D.Va in particularly.
Oh my...
Yeah.
Fuck this D.Va in particularly.
That's right.
Yeah.
Get ready for...
A better...
I almost have a better strafe.
I almost...
It was close.
Now I'm getting away from this fucking Orisa.
Climb up the stairs Orisa.
This... but this...
Y'all friendly?
Bro this is deathmatch.
Go to a skirmish.
If you want friendly matchup.
That's what skirmish... Holy shit!
How is he still chasing me?
Leave me alone!
I'm just gonna run!
There we go.
Leave me alone.
Oh that was a good shot.
Let me full heal.
That was a real...
Yeah?
That's fucking right.
I think there's no Zen here to kick me off.
That's why he chases you.
You chase me, I run away.
It's simple rules.
It's the law of the land.
I hear somebody here.
I hear a Mora.
No heals for you.
Is that D.Va in there with the Mora?
It's fucked up.
I thought I was being smart!
I was like...
Oh I can't... I can't...
It's him!
It's the tank abuser!
I just realized it's him again!
It's the motherfucking tank abuser!
That made me into the monster I am!
Oh my god.
I'm going Zarya.
Fuck this.
Bro.
I'm going to be part of the problem.
I'm going to be...
It's him!
It's him again!
I'm going to be part of the problem.
That's fucking right.
I have better tracking than you, bitch.
Oh you're scared now.
Wait that's not fair.
That's fucking right.
I have good tracking.
Oh he left.
Okay.
This is fucked up.
Because I have to track two Genjis now.
That's fucking right.
Give me that energy.
Oh okay.
He keeps abusing tank in fucking deathmatch!
I had to teach him a lesson but I couldn't find the D.Va.
He was right last time.
I literally bumped into him again!
Oh my gosh.
I'm sad.
I couldn't find the D.Va to teach her a lesson again.
Alright where are you playing?
Venture.
That's an interesting pick.
I feel like I haven't seen Venture in a long time.
I don't want to learn Ilari right now.
I haven't actually played Ilari in a while.
I didn't realize.
If I knew I was going to fucking buff Ilari.
Is it...
Is it a Symmetra?
Wait who was on my team last game?
Was it him?
No.
Okay I'm going to avoid this guy.
Okay I'm gonna avoid this guy.
This guy did nothing.
This guy was actually useless.
Oh.
Oh Lucio Junker.
Okay.
That makes sense.
We have Lucio Junker.
Oh.
Oh, but we're taking so much damage.
We're taking so much damage.
Oh my god, he's also... wait, he's so low!
What do I have to play?
Okay, I should play Bap then if it's Lucio.
God damn it.
All right, I didn't even realize we had Junker.
Come on guys, maybe we shouldn't be in this cubby hole!
Maybe we shouldn't!
Go right, go right, go right, go right!
Yeah, why are you still... exactly!
Okay, that's fine.
Whoa, we did it!
We did have to go right, guys!
We did have to go right!
Guys, I will get the sleep.
Guys, the moment I hit a sleep, we celebrate.
The moment I hit one sleep, we fucking celebrate.
No!
It's fine, we still win this.
Let's see it.
We fucking celebrate.
Guys, it's been a while.
I don't know why, but I'm not hitting sleeps today.
Guys, I used to be so good at sleeps.
Guys, it's okay.
I can do everything else.
Sleeps don't matter as much as I say I sleep.
Matter so much.
Guys, guys!
Guys!
That's fucked up.
That was so fucked up.
That would have hit!
That 100... guys, you know damn well that would have hit if he didn't fucking face.
If he didn't face, that was 100% a hit.
Oh shit.
Wait, did we use B?
Oh, we did.
I should go back soon.
Um...
Hey guys, I'm gonna live here for a sec.
Yeah!
Okay.
Guys, I did it.
I did it, guys!
I did it.
Oh my god.
Okay, here we go.
I have to go BAP because we're running Lucio.
Junker.
It simply is the way.
If we weren't running Lucio BAP, I would run somebody else.
What the fuck is going on?
I did nothing!
I did nothing.
I did not think I needed to use that.
Guys, can we not be here?
Can we go main?
Guys!
Yeah, can we go main?
Can we go main?
Guys, he doesn't want to guard.
The tank doesn't want it though.
The tank doesn't want to.
You're welcome!
Oh my god!
Thank god I was back!
Please!
For the love of god!
Jeez, cool price.
Oh my god.
I was so insistent on the fucking...
Why?
Oh god, I'm debating.
I was like, maybe they have Reaper ult though.
So...
Oh no, I don't feel...
Guys, guys, back up guys!
Back up!
Oh shit.
Oh, this is not good.
This is not good.
I don't have lamp for it.
Yep.
Why didn't I have lamp for that?
No!
Why didn't you beat earlier?
I thought the Reaper was going to TP onto us.
I felt it.
Lucy, why didn't you ult earlier?
You could have ulted and saved us!
Oh my god.
You could have ulted and saved us.
He does do it if it's behind the wall.
If I have the lamp behind the wall.
Before he gets in.
It was better than nothing, you know?
Please, I don't...
I'm going to run here.
Go fuck this.
Oh, okay.
He's on Hammond.
Thank god.
Okay.
Oh.
The only way to live that was to lose the ult.
There's nothing else I could do.
I also put that here... put that there for also the Cassidy.
Thank you, no.
You can come.
Oh my god.
Is our tank the only one not in the voice chat?
Is that why?
Yep.
The very save.
Alright, good luck, Cassidy.
We're trying to save your ass right now.
Like...
God, if he wasn't on...
If he wasn't on Lucio, I would run Zenyatta.
For this Rein.
Nice.
Oh, we got... we got somebody.
I need to save this cleanse though.
Nice, we got two.
Nice, we got...
A legitimate thought.
Okay.
Literally the wrong one to...
Literally the wrong person to boot.
I don't... I don't know what that Lucio was trying to do.
But that was the wrong player to boot.
That's for sure.
I don't think I can.
I'm just making sure that I don't get hit on the side.
Wait, what?
Oh god.
Did I not hit?
No!
No.
You're okay, you're okay.
You're so healthy.
Where the fuck is the Rein?
You're so healthy, Lucio.
You're so healthy too.
Catch my... Catch my heals!
Just catch the heals!
Catch it!
What?
Catch the heals!
Alright, nice.
We're fine.
That's all they need to do.
Never play Overwatch.
The great thing is I'm already a streamer so I don't have...
Stable mental health.
I mean, okay.
Alright.
Let's see.
Woo!
Alright.
Let's go.
It'll be fine.
Oh my god.
I am not fine.
Not fine.
I hoped I was gonna be fine but I was definitely...
I don't know.
I saw that Lucio face tanking a lot.
I...
Yay!
I'm a streamer.
We're not known to be mentally stable.
I would be surprised if there is a streamer in this world that has good mental health.
That doesn't exist when you stream.
It's like the curse.
Is he still... Yeah, I fucking knew it.
I was like, I think he has ult.
I was like, I'm pretty sure.
What?
I clapped my hands!
I clapped it!
Oh, nice.
Nice, they don't have speed.
He doesn't have speed!
Go, go, go, go, go!
He has no speed!
What?
Lucio, you fucking...
He Ajaxed twice.
That was...
He...
He fucking...
He's done it though!
Yeah, yeah.
That seems right.
Yeah, you should.
You should 100% go Zenyatta after that.
Yeah.
Yeah, after what I fucking saw, you fucking should go Zenyatta.
Oh my god, I swear to god.
He's good.
He should.
He was not good.
He...
That... Our Lucio was not a good Lucio play.
He wasted his ult twice.
I saw it too.
Oh man, I didn't... I thought I could...
I thought he was gonna...
Oh no, I have to reload.
No, he didn't...
Okay.
That is interesting.
Okay, that is very... I have to die.
That's unlucky.
That's so unlucky.
I was so confused what the play was.
I was very confused what the play was for this team.
Yeah, that's a GG's.
That is 100% a GG's.
We had a really bad Lucio.
We... Okay.
Hahaha.
We had a really bad support party.
Oh my god.
We lost... beat twice.
In this one game.
Oh my god.
No, we don't deserve that.
Alright, it's time to play the game.
Of...
Avoid Day.
Okay.
Where's my avoids?
Alright.
Okay.
Who is this guy again?
This guy... Oh, this one was the DPS that argued with the Zarya.
Okay.
I...
rather avoid the shitty support player.
That was a terrible support partner.
That was not a great support partner at all.
I did!
I hit one sleep.
Hahaha.
I hit one sleep, guys.
I did.
I just had... My support partner just wasted his Lucio beat like three times during games that we needed.
Like, during last...
Like, he wasted Lucio beats during last fights twice.
That's why he gets the avoid.
A sleep that meant nothing.
It's okay.
A sleep is a sleep.
At least it wasn't an ult.
I wasted an ability.
He wasted an ult.
An ult waste always has more of a precedence.
Maybe I should play Ana to practice.
Okay.
That just means that I deserve that.
Hahaha.
That was mean.
I deserve getting killed there.
Oh.
Okay.
I fell down.
I slipped down.
What the f...
That's fucked up.
That's fucked up!
Okay.
I'm gonna practice Ana sleeps.
That's right.
I'm gonna do it.
It's time to practice Ana sleeps.
No!
I'm fucking around it.
I'm fucking bullying this guy again.
I need to stop doing that.
I hear them.
Okay.
That should have hit.
Hahaha.
I don't care what anybody said.
That sleep should have 100% hit.
That's fucking right Genji.
I can aim on Ana.
I just can't sleep.
I can't see.
Oh.
Oh you're scared?
You're scared?
That's fucking right.
You should be.
You should be scared.
Hahaha.
That's fucking right.
You're scared again?
Hahaha.
I did sleep though.
I slept him.
You wanna try that again?
Yeah?
Are you scared?
Oh you're scared.
Hahaha.
That's fucking right.
Don't do that.
Don't fucking try and push me again.
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
One at a time.
Hahaha.
That's fucking bullshit.
I got two time there.
Every time.
Get away.
You're bad.
Oh.
No.
That's fucking right.
Yeah?
That's fucking right!
Get out!
Hahaha.
I might not haveodo sleep.
But everything else.
That's fucking right!
Oh.
Yeah.
You can only alt yourself in deathmatch.
It's only in deathmatch.
That was scary though.
That was very scary.
I thought I was gonna die to the chaser.
Get shit on.
I might not be able to hit sleeves, but I hit everything else.
Look, I had to fucking kill so many.
I literally killed three people in a row.
I don't know if I could get the fourth in.
I love the streamer mode names.
Those Genjis.
So embarrassing for those Genjis.
Actually.
Actually embarrassing.
My god.
Should go back to the training range.
Oh, we have MAGA!
MAGA time!
Alright.
I haven't encountered a tank that counterswaps yet.
Which is crazy.
Literally all the other games I've had, it was basically non-stop tank swapping.
So it's nice!
Oh, Ana.
Ana, you killed us.
You actually killed us, Ana.
You killed Ana.
You killed us.
I'm going Kiriko.
I mean, Ana.
Alright.
It's Kiriko time.
Ana actually fucked us up.
If I had cleanse, we would have lived.
But I sadly did not.
I'm running double hits again.
Okay.
Oh no.
Double hits cannon against Doomfist.
There you go.
Wait, where's our tank?
Oh!
Our tank is on point!
Why is he on point?
Why is our tank not playing with us?
You're lucky I saved your... Okay.
Guys, I think this is a tank.
Team death.
I think our team is garbage.
Guys, we have a pretty bad tank, guys.
I think.
Our tank is just W king, so we're going to have to follow him.
I think our tank is not good.
Pardon for going last.
Please, I can't.
Please, I picked Sigma.
No!
What?
Who gave this tank everything?
What's his charge?
What is his charge?
Who gave him every fucking utility?
Who shot his punch?
No, it's because like...
The thing is, if you shoot his block...
He had... I think he had max charge, right?
Because like... It fucking gets so much damage.
Somebody shot his punch.
Because like, if his punch is almost maxed out, you can insta...
Okay, I'm not...
But you can't do anything about it.
Basically.
He has ult.
Mei has ult too.
Alright, they're going to Mei ult now.
Okay.
I...
Alright.
I mean, that's great.
I tried my best.
He punched me out!
I collapsed!
I literally collapsed!
This is a good Doomfist, whoever he is.
I saw it!
You guys saw it too!
What server am I on?
Oh, I'm on East Coast.
That makes sense.
Okay.
I'm on East Coast servers.
That makes sense.
That makes a lot of sense.
Nice.
Alright.
Alright, we got...
We backed him off for one fight.
That's all that matters.
Alright.
This Doom is scary though.
Oh, I have to use that.
I was so scared.
I didn't want to die.
It's okay.
He'll be fine.
Nearly wasted anti.
They used Doom ult.
They still have Mei ult.
Um...
They still have Blade.
Okay.
Alright.
That...
Okay!
Oh!
Alright!
Let me just get bullied!
Okay.
Alright.
Oh!
Our Winston is still alive!
Easy.
Oh!
Holy...
Somebody is giving this Doomfist max charge and it's not me.
Because I'm trying to fucking keep everybody alive right now.
Somebody is giving that Doom max charge.
Who is it?
That Doom has so much charge for his punch.
True.
It might be the turret.
I think our doom is just farming our torb's turret.
That makes more sense.
Yeah!
They nerfed our ship?
Yeah, it's so hard to shift right now.
It's like... I need to time it better.
The ship is so fat.
It's so slow compared to before.
Because I clapped and I still get punched.
Which is frustrating.
I think it sucks when you have to relearn characters and timing and stuff.
Especially like not playing at...
The thing is I literally didn't play for a week and they changed so much!
That's the most frustrating part!
They changed so much after a week!
I didn't realize.
Somebody...
I am keeping you up as long as you can.
Please keep surviving!
When you play support a lot, especially the characters that are meta and they change one thing.
Even something small like seconds.
It affects a lot because you have inner timing, reflex timing.
So for me, I have reflex timing for certain abilities.
So it throws me off so much when they change things.
One thing.
Because I'm not used to it.
Alright!
I'm trying to keep you up right now!
Oh!
That...
That guy has so much...
Charge!
Please somebody touch it!
I can't touch it!
I'm trying to keep you up right now!
Woo!
Goodbye!
Please!
I'm literally running around!
Hahaha!
Oh my god!
My internal timing!
I have to manually adjust myself.
Because I can't use internal reflex.
Oh god!
Get me away!
Get me away from that Doom!
I feel like if I let that Doom touch me just once, it's over.
Hahaha!
It's actually...
Oh god!
Goodbye!
Hahaha!
Woo!
Please!
What the fuck!
Hahaha!
The doofus PTSD!
Get away from me!
Hahaha!
Why you even do that?
Now they don't have an Ana.
Oh!
Oh nice!
Nice!
Oh god!
I see the Doom!
I thought he was gonna punch me!
Hahaha!
I reflexively...
Um...
Hahaha!
Who punched him?!
Who the fuck!
Oh shit!
Oh god!
That's not fair!
You had the Doom!
Okay, they used Reaper ult, they used Doom ult.
So that's good.
That means...
Did they Kiriko ult?
I think they Kiriko ulted.
So...
The only thing they are missing is Nano.
Oh my god, everybody!
Everybody always come after me!
Why not the Mora?
The Mora has less...
The Mora has less movement than me!
She looks so juicy and vulnerable!
Oh my god!
Hahaha!
Oh god!
There we go!
Please.
It's him!
Hahaha!
Guys, it's him!
I'm going to point, guys.
Hello.
Ayano, I see you there!
Ayano!
Yeah, I went...
Oh my god.
He's gonna touch point.
Most likely.
Yeah!
He missed!
The Doom missed!
Get the Mora!
Not me!
I literally can't clap my way away!
Mora just has fade!
I'm literally getting hard targeted.
It's actually crazy.
Every time I show up, the Doom tries to punch me.
Yeah, but the Mora!
The Mora is with me!
She has less movement!
Please!
Every time I clap, it's to clap away from the Doom!
This Doom... This Doom really wants to kill me.
It's actually crazy.
Our Tracer is really good.
I will admit that.
Our Tracer has been getting non-stop picks.
He might have the lowest damage, but he's getting the picks.
Or that.
Which makes sense.
Oh, thank god.
Leave me alone.
Oh, he has Max!
Oh, please!
I leave!
There's no point!
He's dead!
He's dead, Mora!
You should have left earlier!
I should have went with Azaria.
I wanted to save... Oh, Orisa.
Alright.
See?
It's going.
The counter swap, but only on our end.
Because the Doom is just better than our counter swap tank.
clap my way away!
No, I saw him.
I saw him get so much fucking ult charge... punch charge.
clap my way away!
Why?
No, I don't want to die.
Oh, no.
I hear him.
Alright.
Come on!
This is winnable!
This is so winnable!
Oh, no!
Just get on point!
This is so winnable!
I swear the guy...
Nooooo!
Guys, I don't think it's winnable anymore.
Guys, I don't know.
I don't know anymore, guys.
I...
Guys, I think we're gonna lose this game.
Guys.
I don't know.
Oh, please don't anti-Arisa.
Please don't.
I don't have... He has Reaper ult.
He has Reaper ult.
I feel it.
Oh, guys.
Please live!
Oh!
It's okay.
It is not okay.
It...
It's okay?
It is not okay right now.
It is...
It is not okay.
I don't feel okay, guys.
I don't...
Please!
Arisa's doing so much, guys!
Help Arisa!
He's gonna die!
Oh!
Moro, why didn't you like sit still for so long?
Help our team!
Help us!
Arisa.
Where is he?
Oh my god, we did it!
For another fight we lived...
We lived along for another fight!
Oh, please.
Please.
Oh, god.
I need a... I have to solo contest.
Oh, my god.
Please.
That's so scary.
I don't want a solo contest.
Oh, god.
Please.
I don't want a solo contest.
I beg you.
I...
God, they got the point though.
They got the point.
Oh, my.
The amount of solo contesting I had to do there.
Go, go, go, go!
Go, go, go!
Go, go!
Nice!
Please kill the carry!
Oh, he killed the carry!
The amount of dodging I had to do is critical.
Bro!
Jesus.
Oh, my god.
It's so...
I had to jump around so much.
Oh, my god.
I can't believe I lived that long on point.
This Doom deserved the win.
We did not deserve...
This Doom literally was hard carrying.
Holy shit.
That was so scary.
That Doom must be so mad.
He literally carried his entire team on his backs.
We did not deserve that win.
That Doom did...
That Doom did so much.
Oh, my god.
Oh, this must be so frustrating.
I feel so bad.
I feel so bad for that Doom.
He actually did so much for his team.
I was climbing walls.
I was dodging.
I was weaving.
I was suzuing.
He made me...
He made me fucking...
I was everywhere.
I was...
I was fucking everywhere because of him.
Jesus.
That was actually so...
Oh, wait.
No.
No!
Oh.
That was so difficult to play.
Oh, my god.
Another one?
That's fucking right.
Okay.
I deserved that.
This way.
Yeah.
I actually have to try so hard there.
I actually have to...
think.
You can tell the difference when it starts getting higher elo games.
My fucking decision making and movement.
You can tell when I start thinking.
And actually play the game compared to before.
There you go.
Get over here.
I should be playing Ana to practice Leap.
Yeah.
I can think.
I know.
Thank you.
That's not fair.
That's fucking right.
You got a free medkit.
I still beat your ass.
No!
The last brain cells.
My last brain cell fucking working on overtime there.
What the fuck?
That's right.
Oh, shit.
Thank you.
I really appreciate that.
Thanks, Ana.
I hear the Ana.
Oh, never mind.
She's dead.
Oh.
Dirty brain expansion.
But you can tell I'm playing Overwatch more regularly.
Because I'm actually...
Oh, shit!
You deserve it!
You fucking deserve that!
Fucking...
Don't!
You deserve that!
Versus whenever I play it after like...
a month...
Not the Maga.
Maga, get away.
Get away.
I will fucking run away.
Run away.
Run away from the Maga.
Where did I go?
I want to...
Where did I...
Yeah, that's right.
Oh my god, the Ana beat him.
Oh my god.
I had to run away.
I was so scared.
Oh, connecting.
Come on, give me a game.
Give me a game already.
That slippery Cassidy.
That's me.
I see tank, I run.
That's how it goes.
Somebody's not...
This lobby is bugged.
Are you serious?
Oh, okay.
Nevermind.
That was a bugged lobby.
Prepare your defenses.
Select your hero.
Alright.
Uhhh...
I play Ana.
Oh fuck.
We have Rein.
I still play Ana.
The awful Symmetra on the enemy.
Oh, it is!
It's giraffe boy!
I still play Ana.
Alright, let's go.
People don't really talk anymore in Overwatch.
They just play.
Guys, you wanna see my sprays?
You wanna see my...
animated sprays?
I'm a legacy.
Look at that.
It's moving.
And then I have this one.
And then... Wow!
It's moving!
And then I have this one.
And I have this one.
And then it only lets you show four.
I'm not gonna show four.
I'm an OG.
It moves!
Yeah!
Are you printing again?
Are you printing
again?
Oh.
Balconies?
What do you mean you didn't shoot the balcony?
You're supposed to shoot the balcony so I know...
So I can shoot through it!
It's the law of the land!
It's Hollywood!
Oh my god!
No, he ate my...
He's eating my...
He was eating my fucking...
Heals and everything.
We can't counter the high ground.
We're trying!
They're behind us!
Oh god.
Oh, we lost Cassie.
Cassie, why didn't you go up?
Oh, he ate my... Oh my god.
I slept!
Oh, thank god!
Thank god!
I don't know what...
Oh god, please!
Please come over to the rally!
What's going on?
Oh, I needed the rally near me!
I wanted to...
No, right!
I needed the rally on me!
Oh no!
Oh, thank god.
At least we have D.Va.
That was hell.
I'm not playing fucking...
Okay.
Okay, so you go in.
Now!
Live!
Oh, this is not where I live.
This is where I die!
I'm not playing Ana!
Oh my god!
That is not an Ana match!
Holy shit!
He fucking ate everything!
There was no way I could play Ana there.
That guy fucking ate all my shit.
Thank you, brother.
I just don't think we should have Kiriko!
I don't know!
I think we definitely maybe needed something that's not Kiriko.
I'm not Kiriko.
I'm Brigitte.
Brigitte.
Sorry.
I was talking about Brigitte.
I'm not talking about me.
Oh!
Leave me alone!
Please!
He has evil eyes!
I'm gonna bomb!
Oh, thank god!
Oh, thank god I lived!
I was not sure.
I was not sure if I was gonna live that.
Nice.
We're doing great.
I'm gonna stay on the ground.
I know I shouldn't be, but like...
I'm gonna stay on.
Alright.
Live!
I don't have cleanse, but live!
Eternate if you can!
I need you to Eternate!
Oh my god!
How are you so low?
I have cleanse.
That's fucking right, but you didn't get cleanse!
Oh, he's so low though.
That's unfair.
This is actually a sim map for him.
I think he's a sim one trick.
I just noticed.
I think that would make sense actually.
Oh god.
Nice.
That's very unlucky for you.
But we have...
I think we have...
What?
He got fucking cleanse?
Please.
Please live.
I can't!
There's too many things going on!
Maybe...
I was gonna say Pharah for the Symmetra.
Because they don't really have any DPS.
Alright, I'm gonna stay here.
I'm gonna stay here so I can swap.
There we go.
I have to go Curacle for the cleanse.
We need to break the swap off.
Yeah.
Give me Zarya?
Zarya would be good on this counter.
For the counter swap.
This is a good D.Va player too.
I literally saved your life.
I predicted you to go that way.
Get predicted.
Oh.
There's a Cassidy behind us.
This is bad.
No, I don't have cleanse.
I don't have cleanse.
Please stay alive for...
a little longer.
Please.
Please stay alive.
I'm sorry!
Our Frigg is not with us!
I tried so hard to keep you alive!
Guys, I...
I think...
I...
I think we have a Frigg one trick.
No, I didn't use my cleanse!
Let me judge you.
You don't even...
Okay.
I wonder what the issue is.
I don't know, Frigg!
We don't need Frigg!
We don't even need Frigg!
Yo, you don't play Frigg!
What the...
What is your account?!
What is your fucking account?!
You don't even play Frigg!
You don't have hours on Frigg!
Oh, okay, nine hours.
He's your least played support!
He's literally your least played support!
Don't understand!
Play... play...
This is a vertical map!
The reason why I don't think Brig works here is because this map is vertical.
Like, this is a vertical map.
You're not gonna be useful.
As Brig with verticality.
Let him have fun!
He can't!
This game is now free to play!
He spent zero dollars!
Except for that Brig skin, maybe.
Maybe the Brig skin he spent money on.
But like...
They can use the skin where like, I spent $40 to play whatever I want.
Oh, now you play Lari!
Okay.
He wants to play fun.
Yeah, play in the ring.
He is smart.
Bro!
I avoided this fucking Symmetra and now this Symmetra is gonna farm me!
This is not fair.
My avoid slots is to be used to gain SR, not fucking lose.
Okay.
Alright.
Don't peek, guys.
Don't peek.
Jesus.
I wish I was Juno right now.
Oh my god!
He's so low!
I have to heal though!
That sucks!
This is a really good D.Va player though.
I have to admit.
The D.Va player is really good.
Oh my god.
I almost have ult.
Oh no!
We're trying so hard to keep you alive!
We're trying so hard!
I'm almost close to ult.
Can we play Pharah?
Can somebody play Pharah?
I think if we had Pharah it would work.
That's just me!
That's just...
The only issue would be D.Va but if you have a pocket Mercy you'll be fine!
Or Zarya.
Wait, why are we playing Zarya though?
I don't know.
Maybe Zarya would be good.
Oh my god.
Bro, that D.Va died literally once.
Bro, Sigma please.
Do not let the D.Va get mech back.
Please!
That's all I want!
There you go!
Go!
Go go go go!
Alright.
I'm dead.
I guess.
They used 4 ults.
I don't know.
This team is...
Yeah.
I don't know.
I don't know, man.
Can we...
Can we get Zarya in?
Where the fuck is our Zarya?
Wait, did we use Elarion?
I don't know.
Maybe... Maybe Zarya would be a good idea.
Guys!
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
Did we do it?
Guys, it's okay.
I got the turret, guys.
It's okay.
You're...
Oh my god.
I thought he was closer.
I actually thought he was closer.
Oh!
This is where I die.
Goodbye.
Thank God.
I don't know who to avoid.
My entire team...
My entire team is a mess.
Who the fuck do I avoid?
Interesting.
I...
You play every tank but Zarya!
How is that possible?
It's just tricky!
Zarya is one of the easiest tanks to play.
Non-tank players play Zarya.
Because she's literally the easiest tank to play.
It's all about tracking and bubble management.
Can you not track?
It's just aim!
People who don't know how to play tank, they play Zarya!
How have you played 30 plus seasons of Overwatch?
Just a struggle!
Oh my god!
Tracking is hard!
We're in Master Elo!
How?!
You should not not know how to track by Master Elo time!
No, fuck this guy.
Okay, I think I'm just gonna void the tank.
I'm gonna void the tank!
Alright, you know what?
I'll get that Zarya player back.
Um...
Just cause he can't play anything...
He can't play Zarya.
I don't understand.
Literally, you go Zarya, attack!
The only verticality is that one place.
He went Rein!
This has to be... Oh my god, it has to be one of those tank players that can't aim!
He literally went like Rein and Winston!
I mean, Sigma requires... He went every tank in the world!
But Zarya!
Like... How do you play every tank?!
We have!
But Zarya!
He played D.Va!
Sorry, I...
I can't use the bath, it'll be right back.
I'm back to suffer once again.
It's just... It's just tanks!
I... I...
I lose because of shit tanks!
Like...
Alan, Kaz, Duck, Miki, Medi, and Neppers!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
I didn't lose because of garbage tanks!
And that's it!
If I have a good tank...
I would... I can like... I can like just keep him up!
And then we win!
Sorry, I couldn't pee the toxicity out.
I tried.
I tried so hard.
I'm so...
That's fucked up.
That's fucked up, Gengu.
I'm nearly 11 HP.
Oh shit!
I can always blame tanks.
You lose because of bad tanks.
It's nothing else.
A good tank can actually 1v4.
We saw that.
We saw our Hog 1v4.
It's true.
We literally saw it in our game.
Then play tanks.
Surely you can do... I'm not a tank main!
That's the thing!
I'm not a tank main!
But they are!
Wait, did I get killed?
Am I red?
No, I'm Shimada.
Oh shit!
That's an actual Widow player.
I'm scared.
This is an actual Widow player.
Did you see what I...
I just waited for him to go across my crosshair.
Because I know he was fucking around.
Don't aim.
I just waited for him to go...
I waited for him to fucking strafe into my crosshair.
That's all you have to do.
If they fucking do that shitty strafe shit...
Yeah, I just let him walk into my dot.
Okay.
I'm gonna go to the other side.
No!
What?!
Who are you?!
You're not part of this Widow fight!
Are you serious?
Come on, Cassidy.
Come on.
Oh, he's over there now.
Okay.
Oh, they're all so far.
There's a Lucio?!
Is this Sombra?!
Oh no.
Is he gonna recall?
Oh my god, he recalled there?!
I was not expecting him to recall there.
Okay.
Fucking nerds.
Alright, where are they?
Oh, are they like chilling?
Where are they?
I wanna chill.
Wait, what?
I wanna chill up there.
No fighting on this friendship rock.
Oh man, I wish I was Ilari.
He's not in the friendship rock.
You're not in the friendship rock.
He's not in the friendship rock!
You said only friendship rock.
This is peaceful.
He didn't say I can't shoot on the friendship rock.
He just said I can't kill people on this one.
Those are fair game.
They're all not on the friendship rock.
Where are they?
Over there.
Is that all of them?
That's all of them.
Okay.
Oh shit.
Come on.
Pick me.
Come on!
No!
I was gonna shoot him.
What?
Why did you pull me off?
He wasn't on it!
No.
I wanted friendship rock.
Diamond 1 to Master 5.
Let's see.
I don't know when to stop.
I'm having a good time.
Not gonna lie.
Uh... Mercy...
Should I play Lari?
One game.
God, I wish it was attack.
I'm not good at Lari.
But if I'm... Okay.
I'll do one life.
I'm not very good at Lari.
Because I don't play her often.
I love how... I like the melee on this.
Boom.
I'm glad that...
Overwatch is doing fun skins now.
Even though I would never spend money.
I don't care as much.
The range on these pylons are insane.
Who is your main in each category?
I play every support but...
Okay, not every.
It's easy to say what supports I don't play.
I don't play...
Lari.
But I'm gonna see if I can.
Because apparently Lari is meta now.
I don't play Lari...
Bap...
Life Weaver.
I think those are the only supports I don't play.
I don't know if there's any other.
I just know that pylon is fucking crazy now.
The range.
Okay, I just want to make sure I have like...
See there's... the fact that...
The fact that like...
Oh!
No, no.
Not my pylon.
Not my pylon!
Alright.
I need to remember that...
Shift is to bounce apart.
Bounce away.
And put the...
I think I'm gonna put the pylon here.
It's the safest.
What the fuck are you doing?!
What the fuck?!
What the fuck was he doing?!
Did you guys see that?!
Oh my god.
I'm fucking dead.
I'm dead.
Oh god.
What the fuck was I...
What?!
Was he stuck?!
What the fuck was our Sigma doing?!
He was...
Okay.
He literally threw that.
We actually had such a good play there.
He actually threw that.
Holy shit!
Oh my god.
I was like...
What the fuck?!
That was so winnable!
Let's see.
I'll put it here.
Okay.
He's on my pylon.
So he's too busy looking.
Oh no.
Are you serious?
Okay.
We got Zarya though.
Oh.
I can't do anything about that.
Best I can do...
Is like... head up.
Oh!
I'm gonna ult and then I'll swap off.
I don't think like Zarya is working for me.
For this team.
I'm not doing enough DPS to justify it.
I'll do it too.
What?!
Holy shit!
Did that Lari got me?!
Oh no.
The Soldier hit me.
Alright.
I'll go Ana.
I don't think they're using cleanse.
They're not using...
Grenade often.
I'm not good enough as...
The Lari.
The player.
Oh god.
I know my limits.
I know my limits when it came to Lari!
Oh I should go...
Kuroko.
I just realized I should go Kuroko because of the Zarya ult.
Oh no!
I need to die so I can go Kuroko!
Come on Winston!
You got this!
Oh he booped everybody away.
But that's okay.
That's okay.
He's gonna farm all the...
Oh he already has ult.
Oh that is not okay.
That is not okay.
No more.
We heal each other.
We heal each other!
That's right!
That ult was useless!
We keep each other alive!
I need to learn Lari.
Holy shit.
If she's gonna be meta.
I don't...
I don't need to play Lari.
Or like...
Learn how to play Lari.
Or... Jesus!
Or like...
Play with somebody that plays Lari.
Because holy fuck.
I don't know if I can learn Lari in time.
That's the thing.
Where's the Winston?
There he is.
Oh!
Alright.
Yeah.
It's more so balancing DPS than heals.
That's like the issue.
When I said he...
Oh he bubbled!
That's cheating!
He bubbled!
Yeah that's what I'm saying.
I need to like learn Lari.
Um...
Off stream.
Because like I can't learn her on stream.
Are you... Okay.
That...
He was way too aggressive for no reason.
Jesus please.
Okay.
I'm okay.
I have nano.
I couldn't swap to...
It's okay.
We're fine.
He's low!
He's so low!
Please!
He's so dead.
I'm so dead.
Oh we're so dead.
Mercy I need you to keep me up or I get starstruck.
Whatever that ult is called.
Okay.
Alright I'm going back.
I'm going back.
Keep me up!
I'm gonna go Kiriko for the grab!
No that's a Lari.
He has all... Oh we don't have all...
This is...
This is bad.
I used cleanse.
Guys I used cleanse!
This is bad!
It's okay he's dead!
Oh he went in so deep there.
It's okay.
We're okay.
We're fine.
Everything's fine.
Alright.
Has our Widow done anything?
Okay he has kills.
Alright.
I just gotta be sure!
I couldn't tell!
I need my cleanse for...
I need my cleanse for the...
Oh!
Okay the Mercy ult!
Interesting pick.
Alright.
This is where we die.
Oh I don't know!
I don't know guys!
I don't know!
Oh!
Goodbye Winston!
Oh shit!
Oh!
Okay we're fine.
We're so safe.
Can we touch?
No no I have to go Lucio.
Get away!
Oh I did my job!
I did my job!
You're welcome!
I touched!
Nobody touched but me!
me!
Oh!
We don't have an Ilari player!
Cause I don't play Ilari either!
Feels bad!
We don't have an Ilari player!
My Ilari is not at this level!
My lair is sadly not this level.
Okay.
Let's see...
Yes!
I don't think Kiriko would be... Oh wait!
We have Hammond, so...
If we have Hammond, I'll go Kiriko.
Hammond is not good with Ana.
Because it's so hard to heal Hammond when he's so fucking... he's everywhere.
Apparently, they've been talking about hero bans for fucking ever.
So like, I don't know.
That's the thing.
Hero bans has been like...
They've always talked about hero bans, but they've never actually implemented it.
They tried in Overwatch League, but then they didn't do anything about it.
So...
Hero bans, it's like League.
You can ban a hero.
Basically.
It's just like League.
So that you just ban a hero.
And you don't want people to play.
So you ban like... I don't know.
Both teams cannot play like D.Va or something.
But like they always... they've done it before.
I don't know if you guys remember it, but they've done it before.
This is not the first time they've done hero bans.
Hero bans was like a thing.
Before.
It was like a long time ago.
Where they tried... like each week... each week they ban a new hero.
Jesus.
He did so much.
I think her Hammond is fucking dead.
Oh no.
Maybe it was easier for Ana.
For you to play something that's not.
Maybe it's better if you don't play Ana.
Because he's eating everything.
He's literally eating all your heals.
All your nades.
Sorry man.
Sorry buddy.
Oh no.
The moment I looked away.
Alright I have...
I think... I don't know.
It's just a team diff.
Like I'm not playing a Lari which sucks for our team.
Because like I feel like my Lari is much more of a...
Much more of a debuff than a natural buff.
Alright.
I don't have cleanse.
But he missed.
He fucking missed.
Nerd.
He actually missed.
What a loser.
Oh.
There you go.
You're alive.
You're fucking...
Alright somebody killed this Ana.
Okay no?
Alright that's fine.
That's fine.
Nobody wants to kill the Ana.
Fuck it.
This is...
It's time.
I think it's not winnable.
So it's time to learn.
I don't think this is winnable.
But it's time.
It's time to learn.
Here we go.
Woo!
Oh he has D.Va bomb.
Oh.
Really?
Woo!
Alright where did you go?
What the fuck?
Okay that's not fair.
There's two of you guys.
It's time to learn Ilari.
No this team?
There's no saving this...
I don't...
We're all just bad.
This is just...
It's literally...
I swear.
I...
This feels like an uphill battle.
I don't know.
I feel like we're not even gonna get that.
We're not even gonna get the uphill battle.
That's good.
Thank God.
Woo!
I'm just gonna try and cat claim...
Claim the land!
Please live!
I'm trying to learn!
We got the play line!
Live!
Get in there!
I'm gonna put this fucking here.
They can't get that, right?
Alright.
Get in there!
He's one!
Let's go!
Get in the pylon!
What the fuck?
Where is this?
Where is the bomb?
I don't even know where the bomb was!
Like, where is the...
No, give me the ult charge, you fucking idiot!
Okay.
I literally could've got free ult charge.
That's the worst part.
I could've got free ult charge there.
Oh god.
Okay, well...
I got pylon up here, so...
It won't get healed.
This is... this is it.
This is your chance.
Alright.
Goodbye, Cassidy.
Hello!
Oh, goodbye, Cassidy.
We tried.
We literally tried our best.
He outdamaged my fucking fly?!
I don't know why he kept staying there, but like, okay.
Weee!
Alright.
But we're... me and the other support is doing so much healing.
Yeah, he could've backed off!
Like, I don't know.
I don't know.
Is that... you know...
Doesn't that seem like, logical?
But like, I don't know.
I don't know.
Maybe I just haven't played this game enough.
Maybe...
Maybe I just haven't played this game enough, apparently.
Oh god, thank god.
We're gonna stay here.
How did our acu- Why?
Wait, why did they all went- Why did they- Okay.
Nothing makes sense!
Nothing makes sense in this game!
It's okay.
I don't know.
Alright.
We gotcha.
Who do we avoid?
Who do we not want on our team in the end?
Out of everybody!
Everybody we fought...
Oh my gosh, not even uphill battle.
That's the worst part.
Is that- I don't know why.
That's the thing.
The guy nano- nanowisered...
To like, one guy.
The guy nanowisered one person.
And then, our Kiriko...
TP'd to the nanowisor.
And I was so confused.
I was like, if you stayed under with the soldier and I...
Maybe she just wants to die.
Like, maybe she really wants to die.
Like, if she really really wanted to...
Wanted to die there.
Just wanted to die a little faster.
I don't remember who Gamma is.
So, I guess goodbye Gamma.
You know what?
Okay.
We'll clean it up.
Um...
Who do we hate the most?
Who did we hate the most?
In the team.
Who do we not want on our team the most?
Guys...
Maybe...
Maybe our...
Our...
The other support.
Because they don't know how to play large.
The tank?
Okay, the tank.
Alright.
Goodbye tank.
Goodbye.
They were all bad.
Like, I don't know how to pick.
They were all pretty terrible players.
As a team.
We were all pretty terrible together as a team.
There was just nothing.
There was nothing.
I couldn't do anything about it.
Couldn't play Alari.
I was not the Alari player.
I mean, I could try playing Alari now.
Maybe I'll start training Alari now.
Oh, you saw that headshot though?
Fucking ran away like a little bitch.
Like a fucking little bitch boy.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Another fucking Rein player.
Bye.
Oh my god!
I'm getting shot by both angles!
The Alari training arc.
This is it.
This is it!
Oh, please!
There were three people on my screen!
I got confused!
Why fucking...
Okay, I need to like heal myself first.
I feel like.
I need to have like a heal beam.
Okay.
Like, I'll take that, you know?
Oh.
Oh, they're all dead.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
They're all dead!
Alright.
Oh my god, Junker Queen, really?
Where's Bap?
No!
I can jump back!
Oh my god, that was so smart!
No!
He fucked me up!
He was smarter!
He was smarter than me!
Sucks.
Don't you hate it when they're just smarter than you?
Really?
Get away!
Leave the rock!
Oh!
That's fucking right, leave!
Leave the rock!
This is my rock!
Whoa!
Not
my rock anymore!
You can have it!
You can have the rock!
I don't want it!
The rock was too scary.
Whoa!
What the fuck is this tank?
Get away!
What is this tank versus tank fight?
Wee-ro!
You fucked this guy in particular.
Ha!
Apparently to activate it, he has to have the rock.
I'm like taking a specific amount of damage!
Fuck that one guy in particular though.
What's that?
Is that my pylon?
Whoa!
That's fucked up!
That's evil.
Oh my gosh!
I keep forgetting that doesn't heal.
I want to use that as like a heal.
For escape...
... ability but it doesn't do that.
I got eliminated by cringe.
I hate it when...
... when they eliminate you by cringe.
What the fuck?
That's right.
Get headshot.
Get headshot, bitch.
Nice.
Come on!
Let me kill this guy first!
Come
on!
Yeah!
That's right!
Come on!
Should've shot my pylon.
That's fucking right.
Wait, where did my pylon go?
Oh, there.
Whoops.
No!
My pylon!
What the fuck?
Who's that?
Where did the Kiriko come from?
Please give me a support that plays Ilari.
Oh, I got Masters 2.
Okay, getting a little serious now.
Masters 2 is top 500.
Getting a little more serious.
Alright.
Can I go...
... Senada?
I can't believe it.
The Kiriko came in...
... to protect me.
Like, where the fuck did the Kiriko come from?
It's like out of nowhere.
Literally...
... turned around and then the Kiriko popped up.
The two kys are subject to the same acceleration.
The threat between them snaps.
Fascinating...
Fascinating.
One more mission, huh?
I'm in.
Alright, here we go.
Oh, God.
I hope they don't play Sigma.
If they play Sigma, I'm gonna fucking swap.
I hate playing Senada against the Sigma.
It's like the worst.
I hope the enemy team doesn't have a Sigma.
Zenyatta against Sigma is not fun to play because of the shield.
Like, I can't shoot anything.
The shield refresh is just too good.
Oh, Rein.
I can play Rein.
Yeah, Rein is good against Sigma.
I mean, against...
He cleansed it.
Oh no, not the fucking Mora.
I'm trying!
How did he die?
How the f- What?!
How did we lose two?!
Already?!
How did we lose two people already?!
Oh, he fucking actually deflected that.
That's actually crazy.
We already lost two people.
Alright, come on!
It's just a run!
He's just walking there!
He missed!
He missed the walking!
Wait, what?
DPS?
Oh no, DPS!
DPS!
We're coming over!
He's low!
Wait, where did Lucio go?
What the fuck happened?
Oh, he's just wall riding.
That's fine.
Let him wall ride!
Let him run!
Oh, he's just wall riding.
DPS, please.
No, he's literally one!
I'm so sad!
He was literally one!
Alright, I have ult soon.
Wait, I have ult before the Ana?
Oh wait, no, because he swapped.
I was gonna say.
What the fuck do I have ult before?
Oh, that's fine.
That's fine.
He's just refreshing me ult.
We're gonna have Mora ult.
And maybe...
Reinhardt?
Maybe?
I don't know.
I don't know if he's actually been doing much.
I have to not get shattered.
That's like the hardest thing.
Just don't get shattered.
Okay.
Wait, what?
I mean...
I'm okay!
I'll take it.
Wait, what?
Try and have shatter.
Still.
I'm scared.
I'm scared of this guy.
Don't worry!
I won't!
I cannot.
I'm sorry.
I'm not a miracle worker.
Holy shit!
Bro, what the...
Oh my god!
I'm not... I'm not...
I couldn't take it for him.
I tried!
I ran in front of it!
I... Did you not see me right in front of it?
I...
I actually ran in front of it!
But I couldn't!
Yes.
Oh no!
Alright, I swap.
I'll go to Kiriko.
Everybody's too split.
It doesn't matter.
Everybody's way too split.
For Zenyatta.
I might be getting kills, but it doesn't matter.
Can you jump up?
I need help.
Can you try to get to you?
We're here!
She's dead.
Get shatter!
Oh, that's fucked up!
Fuck up.
That's fucked up!
We're trying.
I'm trying my best.
Ohhh!
That's fucked up!
We're trying our best to keep you up.
Oh my god!
Please!
Yeah!
Everybody!
You're all so separated!
Oh god.
Trying everything I can to keep you all up.
Please!
LEAVE!
Jesus!
We're alive.
It's okay.
We're okay.
That's why I went Kiriko!
I might have been killing people at Zenyatta, but everybody was everywhere!
There was no point!
Everybody was just everywhere!
Where do I go?
I don't know.
Give me a chunk.
There you go.
There you go, Junkrat.
I don't know why I said Jack.
Zero one, zero one.
Oh!
You're alive!
LEAVE!
What the fuck?
Give me up!
No!
Jackrat!
Please!
Why do we not have a single kill?
I know it's after all of that.
We don't have a single kill after all of that.
It's actually so sad.
How do we not have a kill?
I felt like...
Oh my god, Junkrat.
Holy shi- Oh.
Oh!
Two down!
Go!
We're faster!
Literally two down!
Oh no.
He doesn't have grab.
There's no way.
He'll have it in the next fight, I think.
There's no fucking way he gets grab there.
Okay.
Oh my god.
There it is.
There it is!
Let's live.
Live.
Please.
We're trying so hard to keep you up right now.
Please live.
Okay, I had a feeling that was gonna happen too.
Please!
No!
I can't hear the tire!
If I could, I would!
I would.
Oh, no.
Please.
I can touch.
I can maybe touch.
Zarya one.
We got
on!
But - I don't know how- I can live!
Touch!
No!
The orb!
The fucking orb!
Junkrat, it's you!
Go, Junkrat, go!
GO!
Oh, it's over.
I can't believe it!
The orb wasn't even for me!
It wasn't even targeted at me!
That's the worst part!
Holy shit.
That was actually the worst part.
That the orb wasn't targeted to me.
I don't know.
I don't know what to play.
I guess I'll go Kiriko.
This team is not organized at all.
This team fucking... I don't know.
Maybe it's time.
Maybe it's time to learn Ilari.
This team is not organized.
One life.
One life Ilari.
Alright, I'm gonna avoid the Junkrat though.
Put it here.
This team is all over the place.
We're not playing together.
That's the thing.
This team does not play together at all.
So it's really difficult to heal.
I have to follow one... I can only heal one person.
I have to choose wisely.
One.
Attackers in...
Yeah, the Junkrat is definitely not doing it.
No.
I don't think they got anything with their... at all.
Oh, nice.
Alright.
Oh shit.
I'm trying!
You gotta heal me, yo.
You are very strong.
No!
Alright, I used my one life.
I'll go Kiriko now.
I used my one life.
This is full time.
I fucking... I'm...
I'm...
I'm not... I cannot play Lara against full time.
That's unlucky for me.
Oh no.
No!
I wanted to come back!
That's so unlucky.
Yeah, that was... that was a hard...
Bro.
Where are you?
Where?
Where did he go?
Yeah, this is...
He's over there.
Oh, he fell.
Okay.
That works.
Okay, I don't know if I should... we should chase, but okay.
Alright.
They're not gonna have any ults, because that was such a fast fight.
Oh, I'm doing my best.
Oh.
They have it all.
Separated us all.
Bro, what the fuck?
Why are they all ulting us?
We're dead!
Please!
We're already dead!
We're... they're already dead!
You don't need to keep going!
Yeah, I'm good.
They're gonna gult, though.
Oh.
They're gonna gult.
We have nothing that can counter...
Hymen.
If we have Sombra, maybe?
I think we should get Sombra.
Honestly.
They have nan...
Goodbye.
This is where we die.
Holy shit!
This team's a mess!
We're a mess right now!
Why are we dying?
They're dying.
They have no shield.
Are we dying to die?
We have a Junkrat!
Guys!
Did you not see that we have a Junkrat?
He could be the best Junkrat in the world!
But we still haven't...
Oh, thank god.
This is a...
This area is junk, though.
At least.
Alright!
There you go, Junk!
Yeah, but we don't have enough heals for Brig, Lucio.
That's the thing.
We're running, Lucio.
We don't have enough heals for that.
I have to run a heal-intensive character, and I either go Mora or Kiriko, but we need the cleanse.
Because of the Genghis.
Guys, we just need to hold this for four minutes!
That's fine!
Let's just hold this for four minutes!
Oh, there you go!
They backed off!
I bought us some time, guys!
Guys, I bought us some time!
They're running Czar now.
It's okay!
Now we have...
They lost one fight!
They lost two fights!
That's fine!
Oh my god.
That's good.
He lost his ult charge.
They just need one ult, though.
What the fuck?
Where's our Tracer fighting?
Her demons?
Okay, we have a beat for a grab.
We got...
They are trying to rely on Nano Blade, I think.
Oh, and Echo.
So...
Echo D.Va or some shit.
I can't shoot because I don't wanna die!
I don't wanna die so I'm healbotting right now!
I can't just peek up!
Alright, let's just...
What the fuck is going on right now?
Get over here, get the Zerg!
Nice!
Alright, they still have Nano Blade.
No, they don't!
They just have Blade!
Okay, I don't wanna fucking push that.
I'm not gonna be...
I'm not gonna fucking DPS.
If I die we're fucked because I'm like the main healer.
So I have to play much more safe.
You're gonna have to...
Eat the ground, D.Va!
Eat the ground!
What the fuck?
Okay.
Two more minutes of this, guys!
Two more minutes of this!
Let's go!
Oh, let's not go.
Let's...
not go.
I guess.
Alright.
I won from that.
Yeah, go Rein.
Go Rein.
They have no B, no Blade.
They missed Grav.
I got you!
Don't worry!
This is your one.
Okay.
Two more minutes!
Two more minutes of health!
You wanna swap?
Yeah, yeah.
Go!
Lucille?
Let's go!
Lucille taxi in!
Lucille, we need you in taxi!
Morgan!
No, we're at the point!
This is it!
This is the infamous tank counterswap!
This is the infamous tank counterswap battle!
This is it!
I told you, guys, the fable tank counterswaps battle!
I don't...
Oh my god.
One fight.
Hell has arrived.
Okay.
Is he gonna swap Monkey?
Sigma vs Sigma!
Let's go!
One minute left.
They need one fight.
Literally one fight.
I don't know if they'll have Blaine.
Yeah, they'll have Cole.
They'll have all the support.
I agree.
He's tired.
Go ahead.
Oh god.
Not the orb.
No!
It's fine!
Just get him.
Oh no.
A blade.
I'm dead.
Oh!
Time to get clever.
I'm here.
Where is he?
Enemy here!
Oh!
Enemy coming my way!
Oh no!
It's not over!
Be tuned.
Come here.
It's actually not over!
What?!
That is not over!
Come.
Warrior up.
Enemy up.
Oh god.
Turn around.
How is he in such a good way?!
We're going to need soldier men.
What?!
Oh my god!
What the fuck is this game?!
This is what I mean.
It's the battle of the counter swaps.
The battle of the counter swaps.
What a fucking game.
Oh my god.
What a game.
Okay, that was a good game.
That was actually a really good game.
That was insane.
Holy shit.
Oh, we deserve that.
We fucking deserve that so much.
Like...
Our tanks were just...
The tanks were just counter swapping!
The battle of the counter swaps!
That was insane.
I saw so many different tanks today.
From one game.
I saw a million tanks.
I hate learning Alari.
Maybe I should just play with a support player.
That plays Alari.
I thought I was Kirikou for one second.
That's why I threw him by pylon.
That shit was ridiculous.
Yeah.
He literally went back to zone.
To point.
Just to...
He went back to respawn just to swap.
That's what I'm saying.
All these tanks.
That's all they do.
The world of tanks.
No!
My pylon!
That's fucked up.
No!
Stop!
Yeah, that shit was ridiculous.
Holy fuck.
That shit was intense though.
I was gonna avoid the junk.
But he clutched it.
He clutched it when it mattered.
You know?
What?
Let me go.
Oh no.
That's right.
No!
My pylon!
My baby!
Please!
Leave me alone!
I don't have anything!
I'm literally poor!
I hear junk.
Oh, he left.
Yay!
It's just me.
Oh my god.
It's so scary.
Come on.
I hear him.
Don't worry.
I have my pylon.
I...
Yeah!
I have my pylon.
I...
I still have my pylon.
That's right.
Tomato.
I thought it was tomato.
I was like, oh my god.
I fight myself.
Oh, I hear a...
Oh, that's an ash.
I thought that was a widow.
The only issue is just the wait time.
But like, I understand we need...
Oh no.
No!
My pylon!
Not my pylon!
Oh no.
What?
Okay.
I give him that.
I'm gonna solo alt somebody.
But not me.
Because it'll not be worth it.
Alright, Tomato.
Where are you?
Where the fuck are you?
I'm gonna solo alt you.
Where are you, Tomato?
Where the fuck are you?
Oh my god.
This is a five stack in here.
That's fucking right.
No.
Yes!
No!
He's the only one!
Fuck this.
I'm done.
I'm never gonna learn Ilari.
Oh, the game was like, you're done too.
Even the game was like, you're done.
I'm done.
Alright, let's see.
Is that girl gonna play Mercy?
Cause like they have a Mercy icon.
Is it weird that like every time I see a Mercy icon, I instinctually went Mercy?
It's not bad, right?
Oh no, they have Mercy everything!
Alright, prove me wrong.
They proved me wrong!
They're an Ana player!
Oh my god!
This is why you don't judge a book by its cover, guys.
This is exactly why.
Cause I'm gonna play Mercy.
This is why.
You don't judge a book by its cover, guys!
I'm gonna play Ana one life and then I'm gonna play Mercy.
I should have been playing Mercy on this map.
Mercy is really good at defense on this specific point.
Cause like, the verticality.
Oh yeah, I stole their Ana!
Wait, I shouldn't have played...
Wait, you're right!
I stole their one trick!
Oops!
Really?
I was like...
I'm fucking dead.
I'm like, I brought... I bring him down with me though.
Alright, I...
Oops!
I mean, I like how I said that and I'm like, oh I'm gonna steal their Ana.
Sorry, that's my bad.
Oops!
Accidental throwing, guys.
Are they not...
Tapping the point?
You're still here.
You know what?
No, fuck.
This guy needs to learn.
It can't be a... one trick.
I need to like...
I'm fucking
dead.
No!
Why is everybody not playing together?
Okay.
I'm throwing because I took away... I took away their Ana.
That was my bad.
I'll...
Yeah.
Oh, I forgot.
Whoops.
Goodbye.
Are you on a roller right now?
No!
I wanted to punch the stop sign away!
Yeah, that's not that big of a deal for me.
No!
I was playing as me.
I just wanna use the nano and then I'll...
I swear!
I'm not even doing a lot of healings.
I'll just swap.
I'm sorry, Juggs!
I'm sorry.
I'll just be a Qirka one trick.
There is also a Genji up here.
Yeah.
No brawl.
Give me a hero.
Are they okay?
Oh, wait.
Why would you charge him?
He's one.
He's literally one.
He's still one.
I'm not kidding.
What?
My ult didn't go off!
I was so confused.
I did the whole animation twice.
Are you serious?
Okay, JK.
Sorry.
That was embarrassing.
That was actually embarrassing.
I hit it!
But he's dead anyway!
I'm throwing.
I'm actually throwing.
I don't wanna play Ana anymore.
I'm sorry.
I was throwing.
It's my fault.
I will admit...
I threw this entire game.
I will admit that.
I take 100% responsibility.
I'm sorry.
Oh, shit.
But, even when I swap, guys...
I don't know.
Guys, I think it's just a team issue.
It's not just me, guys.
I don't think it's just me, guys.
I definitely agree.
Thank you.
It's okay, we have next game.
I know when I'm throwing.
Guys, I think I should have went Mercy.
I'm gonna go Mercy during the attack.
Holy shit, we're getting absolutely destroyed.
Jesus.
Oh, he fucking was not there.
I thought he'd be there earlier.
Junk is still one, guys.
Junk is not one anymore.
It's okay, I'm here.
I'm here.
Guys, no.
Oh my god.
I would admit, I threw the first point in the second point.
I threw the first point in the second point.
I don't know, I forgot that he's an Ana main and I took Ana from him.
Oh my god.
Whoops.
I'll be on Mercy duty.
Are you up or are you down?
I'm very down.
Wait, who said that?
Bastion is three to Bastion is five.
There you go, okay.
I'm avoiding him.
Yeah.
Like in one session or like...
Don't worry, I'll be right behind you.
Guys, I don't think it's me.
We were up at first.
I know.
You went from... How?
Did you guys hear what he said?
Five, huh?
Yeah, but then we lost the other one.
You guys heard it, right?
Yeah.
One more, one more.
Did you hear what he said?
Oh!
Master, he went from Master's three to Master's five.
Okay, don't worry.
Don't worry.
Okay.
Oh my god!
He said he went from Master's three to Master's five in one session, guys.
I'm out.
That's what he said!
He's been playing and he went down two ranks!
Literally two ranks!
This team is cooked.
This team is actually fully cooked, guys.
Oh no...
Oh!
Is our Ashe gonna be okay?
Oh, our Genji is not gonna be okay.
Oh please!
I needed help too!
I was getting shot by five different people!
Okay, let me...
Let me see...
There's no...
Wait, what's the voice chat volume?
Where's the voice chat volume?
I can't find it!
Bro needs to stop.
Dude, he does.
This guy needs to stop.
This is not Top 500 easy anymore for this man.
He is getting doom dipped hard.
Oh, god.
I don't even know if I could rez him!
I don't know!
Oh my god!
Oh, god.
I tried to scrape away, so...
Goodbye!
Oh, goodbye!
Woah!
Please!
He chased me!
Oh, yup.
You can search it in the settings?
Wait, you can search?
Okay.
Alright.
No, this is just GG, it doesn't matter.
This whole team is fucked.
Sorry, I avoid...
We might be able to farm this one guy.
We might be able to farm him.
Let's...
Okay.
Um...
Okay!
I think this team is...
We're all special!
It's not just me!
I admit I threw!
But it's not just me!
I admit!
But it's definitely not just me!
Okay.
Yeah.
Yeah, we did it!
We finally killed Doom!
We fucking did it!
We did it, guys!
We made it!
Whoa.
Oh, shit!
Please, somebody kill this Junkrat!
Somebody...
Somebody, please let me...
Somebody, please!
He's dead, he is dead!
He is dead.
Don't worry.
I will ult when we need it.
When we...
When we need it.
Back, back, back, back!
Back!
Oh, okay.
Sleep beg!
Alright.
Oh, okay.
Oh!
Goodbye, everybody!
Get out of our seat.
I'm trying.
NOOOOO I HIT IT!
Oh my god!
I did my job.
I did what I needed to do.
This entire team was just not workable.
You can't do that anymore!
This entire team was a mess.
I would admit, I was also a mess.
But it was a group effort.
It was...
It was a group effort of disaster right there.
It was actually... it was not just me.
My entire team was just a mess.
A mess of group effort.
We all...
We all did not deserve to win that.
I mean the moment I heard this Doom player went...
Yeah, I went from Master 3 to Master 5.
Master 3 to Master 5.
And the other guy was like, in one session?
And I knew...
The moment he said that, I knew it was over.
I knew it!
Oh hey, it's him!
Alright.
Please don't...
Please don't make me be the one to break his win streak.
If I break this man's win...
Like if I...
I'm sorry.
If I break this man's loss streak...
That's the last game for me.
That's the...
That's my last game.
Okay, no he plays Doom.
I'm gonna go Kiriko if he plays Doom.
Oh, Hammond.
I don't wanna play Ana if he's playing Doom.
I'll play Kiriko.
Yo, what works well with me?
I'll play my own path.
That actually works great.
Okay, good.
Alright.
I'll run Kiriko.
I don't wanna play...
I don't wanna play Ana against a Doom.
It's just not fun.
Kiriko's the only fun character to play against Doom players.
If I make this man lose his loss streak, it's over for me.
I'm fucking done for the day.
I'm so done for the day.
That's when I know it's just...
Today's just over.
Come on, kill him!
He's solo!
Yes.
Thank god.
Please, let me just farm him.
Let me...
There you go.
I can clean... I can touch the spot here.
I can clean...
I can touch the spot here.
Oh, Hammond.
Hammond.
Hammond!
No, Hammond!
Alright, this is a little worrying now.
Oh no.
I'm sorry, man.
Alright.
We can't really touch.
But we're trying so hard to keep you alive!
We're trying so hard!
Oh, he fucked up!
Oh, but... He's one!
He's the only one!
I think he's low.
God, he's so low.
Oh, it doesn't matter.
He's not low anymore.
It doesn't matter.
Woo!
I live.
Guys, I think this Doom is really bad.
Even if we lose, this Doom is not a good Doom player.
I think...
I think this Doom is actually pretty fucking terrible.
Like, not gonna lie, he is not a good Doom player.
Oh, okay.
Like, you...
It's so...
It's so noticeable, too.
It's actually so noticeable.
Mario literally won.
It's really noticeable.
Yeah.
I played...
The fact that I played against an ac...
I played against, like, several good Doom players already.
No, 100%.
This...
That's a little embarrassing, that...
He fucking...
Woo!
Hehehe.
Oh, there is Doom.
Woo!
You missed one.
Oh, thank you.
Hehehe.
Woo!
I'm still alive.
I... I fucking... I don't know, man.
It's fine.
Oh my god.
Alright.
We need to kill this Mercy.
We really need to kill...
Alright, here we go.
Alright, I need to stop fucking running from you.
I... I was trying to stay alive.
I was trying to stay alive for the longest time.
Okay, nice.
We got the Mercy.
Bro, he's so low!
Oh no.
No!
Okay, we have one fight.
No, but their Doom is not good.
The Doom is literally getting carried by his DPS.
His DPS is good.
But...
His DPS is good, but...
The Doom is so bad.
Like...
It's actually fucking terrible.
Oh my god.
Actually...
Terrible.
Oh no.
No!
That's so unlucky for him.
I still got it off.
Okay.
Come on.
Come on, Mei!
Come on!
I can't do anything right now.
Keep fighting.
You're literally getting hard carried by DPS.
I need to keep...
Nice, okay.
Nice.
Nice!
Holy shit.
No one's even...
Yeah.
Literally, he's getting carried by DPS and support.
But, yeah.
Oh my god.
Bro.
Their tank, man.
Their tank.
I wanna farm this tank so badly.
Fuck.
I now understand how he dropped from Master 3 to 5.
I understand now.
It's...
Holy shit!
I think that's like the worst tank...
Worst Doom I've ever seen in this elo.
100%.
I've never seen a Doom that bad in this elo.
I think he... He has to be learning!
There's no... I refuse to believe.
Oh my god.
Thank god.
He finally... He needed to swap.
He 100% needed to swap Doom.
He needed...
He could not be playing that character.
He...
He should not be playing that character.
100%.
Jesus Christ.
Oh.
Oh my god.
I can't heal the fucking Hammond.
They're just like...
We don't have our Hammond to help us.
Okay.
Come on.
Come on Hammond!
I'm trying to save you!
We gotta pick guys!
Somebody push!
Fuck you.
Oh.
Alright.
There we go.
They got like 30.
You know.
That's good though.
I'm glad he swapped.
Like...
It was just embarrassing.
You know?
It was just...
It was just embarrassing.
Like... He needed to swap.
He was...
He...
He 100% needed to swap.
This Kiriko is so scared for some reason.
Not Kiriko.
Tracer.
Shit.
Okay.
I'm scared.
Oh Tracer won.
No.
I'm scared.
Oh!
Fuck.
Okay.
Oh.
Wait.
No.
I should... I should stay.
Because of my ult.
I should...
Where the fuck did he come from?
Oh my god.
I wasn't ready for that.
Wait.
What?
Missed the grapple though.
Oh no.
No!
I timed it incorrectly.
That was my bad.
Oh my god.
I timed my E.
I was like, oh I should E.
But then I'm like, nope.
But I got greedy.
I got so greedy.
I'm just glad he's not playing Doom anymore.
Holy shit.
Yeah.
I waited too long.
I was so supr... Oh wait.
He went on.
Okay.
I'll go Zen then.
Alright.
It's time.
It's... it's time?
It's time?
Oh god.
We're trying...
It's time?
Oh god.
No!
We didn't swap in time.
Alright.
It's Zen time.
It's Zen.
Nobody used their ult?
You know, we just didn't have ults.
Alright.
Zen time.
I just don't think we should have Ren.
We definitely should not.
We should have stopped using Hammond.
Is this guy a Hammond one trick?
Am I losing because I have a Hammond one trick on my team?
Is that it?
Is this it?
Am I losing?
Because he can't swap?
Oh, he doesn't go voice chat.
Oh.
Okay.
There might be...
This might be it.
Probably.
No, but they have... Yeah, but like...
Yeah.
Wait.
Oh, thank god.
I was gonna be like... Oh no.
Alright.
Let's shred this hog.
Let's bully this hog, I guess.
And she's not even like a good pick.
It's just that...
I can't see the tank anywhere.
Hammond might die here.
Oh!
He's dead though!
But I am solo here!
I'm healing.
No!
He got it!
They hooked!
Wait, you're not going...
Okay.
If you're gonna go Mercy...
Alright.
Alright, I have to go Ana for the end.
Guys, this might be last game.
Guys, I said if I break this guy's lost streak, we're calling it.
That's when I know it's over.
Haha!
Lost because I had...
Even though this guy was a terrible Doom player.
I have a Hammond one trick.
Whoa!
No hook!
We should push up.
We have one pick.
Here we go.
Whoa!
Hog's half.
No breather.
He's...
Somebody's anti there.
Guys, we have to contest point.
Guys!
Guys, please!
Oh no!
He's so much dea...
Really?!
Why didn't this Doom fucking play other characters in my team?
Oh, this is not good for us.
Oh!
Alright.
Goodbye, Mei.
I mean, that's cool.
I anti'd him though.
That's cool too.
Alright.
Nice.
Oh!
Please!
He's one!
Haha!
Oh, he doesn't have res.
Oh, thank god.
Alright.
Guys, we have one fight if they capped it.
Oh!
Guys, that was a good last game chat.
You know...
We...
They might have...
Um...
The guy actually learned to swap off Doom.
But sadly for us...
Our Hammond doesn't know how to swap off when he clearly is not it.
Hahaha!
But yet...
Sadly...
Our other tank does not know that concept.
Unfortunately.
Hahaha!
Unfortunately...
That is not a concept that he knows of.
Get him!
Hahaha!
The Doom player finally got his big brother that knows how to play other heroes.
Like...
Hahaha!
He got the big...
The big brother that actually knows how to counter swap.
He fucking swapped to Hammond!
Hahaha!
What the fuck?
This is not fair.
I want him to live.
I'm expecting him to live right now.
He's literally nano'd.
Oh god.
That's all that matter.
What?
How did that not hit the anti?
The anti didn't hit.
It was crazy.
Or no faith.
Mara won.
Oh my god.
There you are.
Please.
I slept him.
Guys!
Please!
I never sleep!
Hahaha!
Oh no.
He clearly won.
Hahaha!
Oh my god.
Wait.
We did it.
Yay!
Hahaha!
His last streak continues!
Oh!
Oh my god.
Thank god!
His last streak continues!
That's all I care.
Hahaha!
That's all I care about.
I'm glad he keeps losing.
Yay!
Hahaha!
Keep going down!
Let me keep farming you!
How long have I been streaming?
4 hours?
This is what happens in Overwatch.
You just keep playing.
It's so hard to quit.
Oh my god.
It's 9.
It's so hard to quit, guys.
Oh!
We keep going.
I'm still on Master 5?
Hey!
I didn't rank from Master 3 to Master 5.
I'm like technically up.
Hahaha!
I almost got to Master 4.
But like...
And then I started losing.
And then I lost the points I gained.
So...
You win some, you lose some.
It's the way of Overwatch.
Sadly, Overwatch...
You just don't win.
You don't win.
No matter what.
Because you're playing the game.
What do you mean?
I'm Master 5 right now.
See?
Oh my god.
I'm almost...
I almost won 50 games.
Do I really want to win?
I will call in a duo.
To play tank.
Hahaha!
And all I do is just nano them.
That's literally it.
That's the way to climb for real.
I just need to call a duo tank or a duo Ilari.
Alright, next game.
Oh, it's not him!
Master 5 and Master 3.
Okay.
It's getting more competitive.
Yeah, you win by making other people lose.
Alright.
Push.
I thought I avoided push.
I had so many games that are not push.
That I enjoyed.
I had so many games that I was so happy about.
But like...
I guess, you know...
Happy has got to stop somewhere.
I had to stop feeling happy.
Today.
Like...
It knew.
The game knew.
We will find tranquility.
The game was like...
It's time to stop being happy.
We want you to play a push map now.
So sad.
Siri, please play Despacito.
I hate... Yeah, I played the new push map.
I played it.
No happy.
You're right.
Nobody is actually happy when they played Overwatch.
And the best game I had...
Was the last game.
Because of my...
Because I finally slept some players.
And also that Kiriko match.
Against that really fucking good Doom player.
Oh no.
Not...
Yeah, I'm not playing Zenyatta.
I'm not playing Zenyatta.
They literally have to...
They literally have to have Hammond and...
That is not a fun comp.
That is not fun.
That is actually not fun.
That is like...
It's time to stop having fun.
Alright.
Two bully Zenyatta players for this.
Can I go...
Alright, I'm gonna play Mora.
Alright.
Ana, you should swap.
You're not gonna have fun.
You're 100% not gonna have fun.
They literally have Sombra.
Sombra Hammond!
That's the day that Fun died.
Aww, he was so low too.
Oh, nice.
The day...
The day... Spun had died.
Are they still pushing?
Oh shit!
It's okay.
I got you.
He's still alive?
Alright.
We run away.
I am not playing...
I am not playing... any non-mobile characters.
Also, I'm tired of playing on...
Also, I'm tired of playing on... Kiriko.
This Ana can swap to Kiriko if he wants to.
I'm fucking tired of Kiriko.
I played so much Kiriko today.
Because nobody else was playing Kiriko.
It sucks.
Whenever they have Ana, you have to play Kiriko.
So nobody is happy.
No one gets to be happy!
Oh no.
Please, just touch me.
There we go.
Nice.
Get him out!
Alright.
Thank you Ana.
Goodbye Ana.
I did not think you would actually die.
Goodbye.
Holy shit.
The enemy team is actually antifun.
This is the most antifun team I've ever seen.
Fucking...
Sombra, Mora, Hammond.
That is so antifun.
Oh my god.
You guys wonder why I'm tapping?
Because you regen your heals faster if you tap.
All right, I'm gonna do something stupid.
I'm gonna do something really stupid.
They're all gone.
Oh shit, okay.
All right, I'm sorry.
I can't heal you guys there.
That's good.
I'm gonna keep you up so you can...
Guys I tried.
All right, we did it nano.
Oh, our other team got separated by the Hammond.
Please somebody play Sombra!
Anybody play Sombra!
Braink does nothing against this cop because they have a Sombra!
It's so easy!
This is a counter anti-fun!
We just need a Sombra!
That's literally it.
If we want a counter anti-fun, just go Sombra.
Oh my god, I'm sorry man, but like I'm fucking...
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
This team.
You know, the best thing about push is a curse.
But the best thing about push is that when your team is garbage, it ends faster.
So thank god.
Thank god for that.
And people were like, why don't you play?
Why don't you play Braink?
Because they literally have Sombra.
And like all Sombra has to do is hack me and I'm fucking useless.
That's why it's like...
We need... we need...
We need end...
we need it and we need our own team Sombra to just make the Hammond like...
swap.
Because the Hammond is the problem.
Catch it!
Come down!
Clearly, that's it.
I'm always running out because I can't build charge!
Oh god, D.va.
Please, D.va.
I do not have enough charge for you.
Please.
Please, D.Va.
Please, I literally... D.Va, please.
Please, catch the orb!
Oh, no!
No!
No, Ana!
I got you, Ana!
Please!
Wait, where's our fucking Ashe?
Ash!
When the fuck did he Ashe?
You play Reaper, but non Sombra?!
Okay...
I'm not blaming the tank, I'm blaming our DPS!
The easiest counter to Hammin is a Sombra, and all he has to do is hack him 24-7.
So he cannot be... you don't have to be useful.
You just hack him!
That's literally it!
You don't even have to be useful!
You just hack him 24-7.
Let's hack him.
You run Reaper but not Sombra.
He's clearly willing to swap.
Our tank... our tank... there's nothing he can do.
Unless he runs... like... I don't know.
I don't know what he can run as a tank.
But like, we can do something about... this Hammond.
We can...
Did you see that?
Our Eagg... our tank...
We're gonna shoot at this Reaper.
Throw him... bro he understands.
He fucking...
I thought so too.
What the fuck are you shooting?
At least I'm not the only one that's going, huh?
He knows.
Even he knows.
Even he's like, what the fuck?
What the fuck are you gonna do?
Oh my god.
That's on him.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god.
I need my fucking charge here.
Jesus Christ.
I'm just gonna do this to fucking survive.
Okay!
Ummm...
Alright.
Guess I'm just gonna suck a little harder here.
Just gonna push it.
Goodbye... goodbye...
I'll see you later.
Goodbye...
Let the push commence.
I get to push it a little... more.
Cure for all the dames.
They stole the robot from us!
Goodbye...
Whoa!
Okay, everybody chased.
It's okay, I got... I was able to push it back.
That's all that matters.
What the fuck is wrong with this?
Oh shit.
I'm always persecuted.
Oh my god, our team... our team.
Bro!
How?
We are trying our fucking best!
You're on Reaper!
Where do you learn from?
You're literally on Reaper.
And I'm surprised our Ana is still on Ana.
After like... this world of pain.
I'm just surprised... he's still willing to go fucking Ana.
It's not fun.
There's a reason why I'm not playing fucking Ana.
It's not fun at all.
This is like... yeah, like I said, it's literally anti-fun.
Oh my god.
Okay.
See, this is all you do, you hack!
You hack!
That literally could be you!
That's literally you!
That's literally you Ana!
Okay.
We gotta go there.
Are you serious?
No!
I died above all!
I didn't think I was gonna get hit but I didn't see the diamond of light!
Please Ana, please.
I've made you...
I've let you live for so long...
I need you to live.
I didn't see the dynamite.
I was trying to hide.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Everybody is so critical.
No, no, no.
Catch the orb!
I can't get to people!
Oh god.
This is bad.
This is so bad.
No, he's so...
No, he's... No, no, I have... I can't.
I cannot play with this team.
He's so... for now.
I have to see Sombra.
Okay, we're gonna see who is the Reaper.
After everything we've been through, he was Sombra now.
Oh, wait.
Did you see how impressive their Sombra was?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, that was...
That was the most...
That was the game of all time.
That was truly the game of all time.
Is there a gun game?
I haven't seen like an actual gun game.
Oh wait, no, it's an arcade.
I forgot.
They like took away gun game in custom and put it in an arcade.
That sucks.
I wish there was gun game in...
Waiting for Q.
Oh my god.
That was...
That was the worst.
That was actually the worst.
Alright, this is my last game for real though.
Loss or win.
This is my last game for real.
That was fun though.
I love Overwatch, Frank.
Cause...
When you're...
Don't take it seriously.
Despite how much I was raging, I was not taking it seriously.
This is...
This is my last game for real though.
Let's see.
We'll practice Sleep Dart.
We'll practice our Sleep Darts.
Can I end on a loss?
Yes.
That's a bait.
That's a bait to make you like fucking play this game forever.
You can't...
You can't fool me.
You can't fucking fool me, guys.
Cause then you're like, oh, if I win, you guys would be like, oh, but you can't like...
You can't just like end it...
You can't just end on a...
On a win streak.
And then it's a cycle.
You guys can't fool me.
You can't fool me.
I was like... I know that experience.
How many points do you have to do?
4 minutes?
Oh!
You had to hit that one shot.
I swear.
If I got hit by that...
Look at the sleep dart.
Where is he?
Whoa!
No!
I can't shoot down!
Nice.
That's fucking right.
How do you... what's the winning point?
Why is there... oh, they added a bot that advertises their Discord.
What?!
You won because of ping.
Am I Mug Meal or no?
I'm ChaCha.
Okay.
It's so hard to sleep.
It's like...
It's much easier to just shoot your gun.
Where are you?
That's fucking right.
Are you behind me?
Hello?
Hello there.
Hello.
I'm in Eve.
That's right.
Where am I?
They didn't see that.
Alright.
Master 5 to Master 4.
Select your hero.
Let's go.
Alright.
Let's see.
Defend.
Alright.
I want to play Ana.
Is this where we're playing Ana?
Literally, one is an actual...
It's an actual...
What's the word?
It's an actual player's name.
I remember.
Before like streamer mode was a thing.
This is an actual player name.
Zip.
I got waffle on tank.
Who is waffle man?
Do I remember waffle man?
Is he in my game?
Yeah.
Isn't Icy also a pro name?
Yeah, but Icy is a DPS player.
This is not the real Icy.
There's no way.
Is this a real Icy playing fucking Mora?
No, this is a Mora main.
Yeah, guys.
I don't think this is the same Icy, guys.
This is Icy the fucking Mora one trick.
Holy shit.
The fucking...
Yeah, I don't think that's the same Icy.
Widow.
Ooh.
Ooh, King ending the game on the best map in the game.
I think that's the best map in Overwatch.
That's great.
I like that.
I like that they're ending it here.
I love...
Oh, that's fucking shit.
They have...
This is bad because they have Ana.
Woo!
Mora!
What are you doing, Mora?
Goodbye.
Woo!
Somebody do something about the tank!
Nice.
Yes!
That's right.
You can't do shit.
Nice.
Sucks for this Rein because usually the tanks will do like an honorable Rein 1v1.
But like our waffle man is not honorable.
You can tell.
Oh, they swapped off.
Swapped off.
Swapped off Widow, which is nice.
So I can...
I don't have to worry about peeking.
Now I can peek forever.
Oh!
All right.
That sucks.
Oh, he's one!
He's one!
One!
Okay.
Where did he come from?
Holy shit!
I...
What?
Okay.
That's a good Alari player.
Oh my God!
Where the fuck did he come from?
He jump scared me!
Actual jump scare.
He has shatter soon.
Gotta go on.
I'm gonna...
Oh God.
We lost the doom though.
We got...
We need to get on point.
No!
We got the exact point!
Please!
Do we not have ult?
Oh, Ashe did not have ult.
Yeah, nevermind.
Ashe did not have ult.
Holy shit.
That could be me.
That Alari is insane.
This is what I mean.
We do have a good Alari.
Or a...
A good Alari can fucking carry.
We do have a good Alari and...
Or a good tank player.
Doesn't matter what role you are.
We can carry so hard.
Or you can climb so hard.
Maybe I should have nano the doom.
I just went with the first person I see.
I see!
If you're gonna be, I fucking...
Fuck off.
Actually, fuck off.
Guys!
I told you!
I can sleep!
I told you, I can sleep.
Oh, he missed.
Ashe?
You're lucky I'm fucking pre-healing you.
Alright, Ashe!
I'm fucking leaving, Ashe.
I'm gonna heal somebody else.
That was a good decision by me.
Told you guys I can... I know how to fucking... I know how to sleep!
Bro, is this kid?
That's a child!
Or a girl.
Suddenly... I can't tell.
I couldn't tell.
Was that a child?
I can't tell!
Oh, that's a widow.
Okay.
You gotta come over here.
Maybe both.
Could be.
Oh god.
Oh god!
Please!
He's won!
No!
It sounded like a child!
Hello... Hello... I think he started saying... Hello, Mora?
I think he was.
I think...
It would have been so sick.
Heal the headshot?
I can't.
Okay, no.
It's not a child.
You get a headshot, I can't heal that, bro.
Never mind.
Not a child.
Just a southern accent.
Definitely not a child.
Bro.
Oh my god.
No!
I jumped!
Never mind.
It's a woman.
Sorry.
I thought that was a child, but the southern accent threw me off.
You're laughing at my heart at that moment.
The southern accent threw me off, that's for sure.
Oh my...
Alright.
Not peeking the widow!
Don't peek the widow!
Oh!
This is where our Ramatra dies.
Unless...
This is definitely where our Ramatra...
This is...
This is 100% where we...
Where he dies.
Nothing can save him.
Oh my god!
Goodbye.
I stay here.
Holy shit, he's taking so much damage.
We are trying our fucking best here.
Alright, go Waffle!
Go!
Jesus.
Okay.
Go Waffle!
Go!
What the fuck?
He's actually won!
I swear to god!
Where did he come from?
Where the fuck...
Where the fuck did Waffle come...
Not Waffle.
The Hanzo come from.
Dude, double sniper is so scary.
Is he still double sniper?
Okay, thank god.
Okay.
Single sniper feels a lot more manageable though.
Oh!
Oh, and he just died!
Off I go into the world of fucking...
Cover.
Whoa!
Other Widow's dead, we don't have to run.
We still... What do you mean we still need to run?
Okay.
It's... It's even.
Alright, there's nothing I can do with that.
Jeez.
Please.
Please, Madison.
I'm trying to pick you up right now.
Please.
Oh my god, live.
Live for me!
It's over!
It's okay.
We can push that far!
Right?
It's manageable!
Guys, in two hours I have the meeting.
I think I played Overwatch a little bit too long.
I was like...
I was not supposed to play Overwatch this long, but I couldn't help it.
It was just so fun.
Hey, guys!
I cancelled the round out!
Okay?
I literally...
I'm gonna avoid this moral play forever.
It doesn't matter.
One trick should not exist in this game.
I'm gonna avoid her so that in the future I don't bump into this person.
It doesn't matter if, like, she's good or not.
She's still a one trick.
I hate one tricks.
This game has evolved to the point where one tricks should not exist anymore.
We wanna win.
Yeah, but I might be playing tomorrow.
I'm trying to end Top 500 this season.
Yay!
Isn't it the only sleep you've hit?
That was the sleep that mattered!
It doesn't matter.
It ma- No!
I slept two people!
I literally have stats on my screen!
You can't fucking gaslight me.
There's literally numbers on my screen.
Ooh, that's a really good anti though.
Let's move out!
Alright.
That's a good ana.
Because he knows his, um, maid.
I see a lot of fucking maid players right now.
Guys!
Break the wall!
I should not be the only one shooting that wall.
Like...
I actually should not be the only one.
Please.
Oh, come on!
God.
No, I had to reload!
I'm so unlucky!
I literally had to reload!
Yeah, but they do have an ana, so...
It's like, it's a little risky.
Ooh, he's shooting me.
So...
Oh, I thought he'd be there!
Bad prediction.
No!
Oh, nice!
Oh, no, that's not nice!
Not nice!
Nice!
Nice again!
Not nice!
Not nice at all!
Why did nobody die?
He got back to help me!
What the fuck?!
Nobody came back!
Am I not...
Am I not important?!
Nobody came back for me.
Literally a fucking tank ran at me!
And he forgot about me!
That's so fucked up.
That's actually so fucked up.
Their ana is really good though.
Because like I said, they know like me, loadouts.
SOMEONE PLEASE SHOOT THE ICE!
We have 2 TPS that can't shoot ice blocks!
Who's gonna nano the Bob?
Who froze?
Nobody.
Okay.
Do we have a Bob?
FINE GUYS!
I...
Guys, how can 3 people just not shoot her?
Look at their HP!
No, our team's...
Oh my...
Guys, I...
I can't...
I...
Let's see...
I don't understand how our team did not kill the Mei.
I...
I don't understand!
That was...
I...
I saw the kill feed and that should not have happened.
Her HP was not going down fast enough.
Holy shit!
My god, this is the last game.
I...
No!
Why would you not...
The wall!
I can't...
I can't this game.
He has ult.
The row mantra has ult.
I can't this game, man.
I...
I actually can't.
Oh god.
Please.
Oh...
The only reason I use it is to keep you alive.
Oh god.
Oh...
Come on.
Oh come on.
Come on!
Oh fuck this team.
This team is very special because it is my team.
I feel like I should go Kiriko for the cleanse, but like I feel like we definitely need that Ana.
Are you...
He's one.
He's so low.
I see.
Oh god.
Thirsty.
Please.
Hanzo, please.
Oh my god.
I feel like we definitely need...
We need the fucking... Please don't stand there.
Please, they have a Widow.
Please.
I do not... Please.
They have a Widow.
I do not feel good of you standing there like that.
It makes me so uncomfortable.
He has ult too.
Oh, he's so low but... Oh, he ulted him.
He has ult.
The Reaper has ult.
I can feel it.
He has ult too?!
Please.
Where the fuck is the Reaper?!
Oh, he's back there.
Alright.
He's gone.
Reaper's gone.
Whoa!
What is this patch?!
What is the patch that he's mad about?!
Which one is it?!
Thing is, I don't know what he's mad about.
I don't know which patch.
There's so many things to be mad about but I don't know which one.
I don't want to look at him.
Oh, they're going Hog Counters now.
Oh, they went Maga!
Oh, they won a win.
Let's fuck it.
Get this Maga out of our game.
Get him out of our game, please.
That's all I want.
Get this guy out of our game.
Get him out!
Okay.
Yay!
That's fucky, right?
Sleep to win that on.
That Reaper waited his entire life for that ult.
That's so... That's where he came from?!
The sleep that mattered, baby.
He waited his entire... He kept that sleep for so fucking long.
Making GG's dogshit Reaper.
I wonder if that's something I play in the game.
I hope it is.
Okay.
History.
King's Row.
I want to see that.
Oh, no.
Not save.
I want to...
I want to see that.
Ended on a win.
Is it... Is that... Hello, CF Cogar.
It is.
Embarrassing for the Reaper.
So embarrassing.
Holy shit.
That shit is so embarrassing for him.
Rip Bozo.
That was fun.
I had a fun time.
We're up.
I think I need like one game and I'd be Master 4.
But we're up.
I mean, it's pretty good for solo queue, honestly.
Like, for solo queue in general, that's like pretty good for me.
Being up is always good, guys.
No matter what, as long as you're like...
As long as you're positive in your climb, that's all that matters.
So I'm happy.
I'm happy that we're positive in the climb.
Yeah, just one... I was... I did have a lot of fun.
I always have a lot of fun when I'm streaming rank.
Not when I'm like...
I mean, I do have fun off stream.
It's because I don't take it as seriously.
I don't take it as seriously anymore.
So like, it's only when I'm like...
It's only when I take it super seriously that I don't have fun.
But streaming rank, playing it, and streaming for you guys, I definitely enjoyed it a lot.
Alright, I'm gonna head off now.
But thank you everybody for watching!
Tomorrow we have Marvel Rivals, so we can compare directly to Overwatch.
And they are releasing a couple of new characters for the closed beta.
So it's gonna be fun to see.
I'm gonna call it here, everybody.
As always, everyone, stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Because you deserve it!
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys!
Bye!